we got uh really crazy news two
absolutely shocking stories the first I
did not believe it when good sir Brandon
read it I said there's no way that's
true the governor of New Mexico has just
decreed the possession of guns to be
illegal
that that's that's the headline I'm not
exaggerating I didn't believe it when I
heard it granted there's some Nuance to
it but outright the governor has
declared a public health emergency in
which it is now illegal to possess a
firearm in public even though the state
is an open carry state this is
I'll keep it light for the intro but for
those that know their history when
Executives declare the seizure of
weapons typically historically in many
places really bad things follow that I
am uh extremely worried to hear this
news breaking today and um 10 minutes
ago uh maybe about 20 minutes ago
on top of this new information is
breaking with the release of the grand
jury recommendations
the grand jury in Georgia voted to
indict
sitting members of the Senate including
Lindsey Graham three
and funny Willis has just declined those
indictments
understand the uh I mean this is
let's just uh start over
the grand jury in Georgia
voted to indict three Republican members
of the Senate
New Mexico has just decreed
the possession of guns to be illegal
this is going to be a fun episode
before we get started hey join us live
in Miami while you can I guess go to
tipcast.com in the little menu bar there
is a link to the timcast IRL in Miami
event
it's from 6 to 10 30 October 6th it's a
Friday Don Jr Matt Gates Patrick Bet
David me Lou gradkowski and Ian we're
all going to be there and we're gonna
have a pre-show for you a bunch of free
stuff from companies that are a part of
Public Square the whole event is
sponsored by Public Square I think
Public Square is one of is the tip of
the spirits one of the most effective
and one of the most important Tools in
winning the culture War building a
parallel economy and it is an honor and
a privilege to have them as our as our
main sponsor for the event and only
sponsor
so we really really do hope to see you
there uh tickets available at
timcast.com smash that like button click
join us become a member no members only
show today but you can support us
directly by uh becoming a member I I
gotta shout this out too because I
haven't done this when you become a
member you get access to our Discord
server on our Discord server it is a
Vibrant Community where there is a
pre-show I believe there's a pre-show
there's an after show where members of
tip guests.com hang out and continue the
conversation there there are communities
that are working on projects sharing
ideas developing games and we've been
actively shouting out every Friday we're
not doing it this week because we got to
promote the Miami event
but every Friday or I should say we try
to for the past several Fridays one of
our members gets the ad space so Friday
is a dedicated ad to one of our members
and we shout out your company and uh
because you guys are the the backbone of
everything we do so we really do
appreciate that this is going to be
really interesting smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
joining us tonight to talk about this
and a whole lot more is Brandon Herrera
thanks so so much for having me man I
appreciate it thanks for coming who are
you what do you do so uh my name is
Brandon Herrera I am uh well a YouTuber
on the internet I talk about guns gun
safety try to uh blend entertainment and
comedy with you know trying to teach you
know Second Amendment activism uh
firearm history all sorts of things but
also more recently I'm now running for
congress against incumbent Rhino uh Tony
Gonzalez in uh CD 23. we're we're uh I'm
I may be one of the most to a
absolutists you'll ever meet uh
if you've I don't know if you've ever
heard the arguments I've made but I've
even argued with Republicans about the
right to keep and bear nuclear weapons
and biological weapons and I have and I
am a fan and I would love to talk about
that
um because it's not a question of
whether or not it's morally correct it's
a question of legally allowed or
protected and I'm of the position that
uh you're allowed to keep and bear arms
and arms is Broad I would love to get
into that with you because that is such
a fascinating time it's funny when I'm
talking to politicians and I'm like can
we have nuclear weapons they're like no
no I don't know if I agree with that but
uh uh anyway we got Phil here hanging
out how you doing I am Phil Labonte I'm
the lead singer of All That Remains I'm
an anti-communist account a
revolutionary I'm also pretty
anti-communist these days still hi
everyone Ian Crossland happy to be here
let's roll
we got Carter what's up guys taking a
break to update Pro Tools and stuff and
filling in for Kellen and serge so let's
do it here is the first story from the
Santa Fe New Mexican and I'm going to be
as uh um deliberate in my introduction
here first governor bans carrying guns
in Albuquerque after 11 year old killed
Let's uh you wanna pull that article up
could you have that there you go and uh
News Guard certified 100 out of 100.
I I I can't believe this Governor bans
carrying guns in Albuquerque after 11
it's not just Albuquerque it's uh
there's like a Metro limit
Governor Michelle Luan Grisham on Friday
announced a new Public Health order that
she said will ban people from carrying
firearms either open or concealed in
Albuquerque and throughout the
Bernalillo County for the next 30 days
regardless of whether they have a permit
Grisham a Democrat issued an executive
order Thursday evening declaring gun
violence a public health emergency
this is beyond unconstitutional
but I will tell you this right now
I'm willing to believe the police with
smiles on their face will will arrest
you if you have a weapon the order
States no person other than law
enforcement or licensed security officer
shall possess a firearm either openly or
concealed with cities or counties
averaging 1 000 or more violent crimes
per 100 000 residents per year since
2021. so because of that it only applies
the City of Albuquerque and Bernalillo
County Luhan Grisham said and can only
be enforced by New Mexico State Police
whose presence in the state's largest
city would be significant over the next
month
we've seen this kind of things happen in
various countries happen throughout
history and they almost always I think
it's fair to say always
lead to very very very awful outcomes
sometimes it takes a little bit longer
for the awful outcome but uh typically
disarming the population by decree
results in active conflict between the
citizenry and law enforcement and um oh
I know all of these libs are going to
get so bent out of shape when I say this
but for those of you that know American
history you will know that the first
battle which wasn't really even a battle
of the American Revolution was because
the crown was trying to seize the
weapons from local militia basically
farmers who got together and said we do
not believe these laws are Justified and
they went and said okay well we're going
to come take all your guns from you and
they said no you're not
when uh uh we're setting up the show
what's the big story I always ask and
we've got this huge story about the
Georgia grand jury indicted voted to
indict three sitting members of the
Senate Republicans and only because the
Democrats like now we're not going to do
that it didn't happen even though this
is what the grand jury does
this is where we're at right now in this
country and then Brandon over here says
New Mexico just banned by decree uh
carrying weapons and I'm like no no
that's wrong that's wrong Googled it and
I'm like no this is just some kind of
like platitude there's some kind and
then uh friends like nope Santa Fe New
Mexico he literally just came up in my
Instagram feed the first time I looked
at it I'm like ah you know maybe this is
somebody being a little dramatic on
Twitter because you know sometimes
people you know they they see a story
and then they extrapolate something
that's not quite correct like it's not
all the way verifiable they just kind of
go their own way with it but sure enough
looked into it and that's exactly what
it seems like just happened I will say
Arizona didn't ban guns as some Tyrant
is attempting to and that's pirate or
New Mexico thank you very much New
Mexico didn't ban guns some tyrants
trying to and it's up to the people of
New Mexico to decide whether or not that
tyrant's gonna speak for the people this
is this is the the uh inflection point
the question we have right now is is it
a legal executive order
and the question for a person in my
position is
what advice do you give the average
person
uh I first of all I think that it's
clearly unconstitutional there is no
provision in the constitution in the the
Federal Constitution the United States
Constitution that empowers Governors to
revoke the rights of any citizen under
any reason so or to create law fair
enough true
um so there's that so first of all right
off the bat it's unconstitutional you're
gonna have to have people get together
peacefully open carry peacefully
disregard the law and you're gonna it's
gonna have to be a it's not a law though
well this is the degree this is the
question I have
we my position is almost always you know
we challenge the law through the legal
system when when legislatures pass laws
it's something we have to get active on
with knocking on doors and filing
lawsuits many of these laws are unjust
and get removed instantly it is
extremely likely that this thing is
going to be struck down
almost immediately however the governor
did it on a Friday intentionally so that
she's guaranteed a few days of this
being in effect which is using the
procedure as the punishment
what do you say to the average person
this is not law
this is unconstitutional and I would
argue should be considered seditious or
illegal on the part of the government
should be illegal it should be a
criminal act to subvert the Constitution
yeah it is actually the question is who
will the police in what direction will
the police start to enforce this
do we then say You must abide by decree
of Governor well that's not legal in
this country
in which case we would say to people
disregard decree of Governor well now
you've got police saying you're inciting
criminal actions or something to that
effect the law is broken the legal
system has shattered you're saying if
you tell a cop in New Mexico to defy the
governor that you're committing a crime
no if you tell someone they should keep
and bear arms regardless of the decree
you are now inciting someone to ask per
the governor's view violate their Public
Health order under executive powers
which is not law but the police will say
you're inducing someone to commit a
crime so I did just look this up this is
kind of interesting because like I agree
with a lot of that like there there is
no provision that allows the governor to
defy you know the Bill of Rights that's
very basic but they're having State
Police enforce this which is why I was
really curious what the the New Mexico
state constitution says about it so
article two of the uh constitution of
New Mexico provides quote no law shall
abridge the right of the citizen to keep
and bear arms for security and defense
for lawful hunting and recreational use
and for all other lawful purposes but
nothing herein shall be held to permit
the carrying of concealed weapons
which was kind of interesting so this is
the New Mexico Bill of Rights section
two and uh right to bear arms is Article
2 Section 6.
and uh it's exactly as you said we have
it pulled up here and this was um it
looks like as of November 2nd 1971.
so the governor if the police
I'm hoping the police just say here's
what needs to happen we need a statement
from the head of state police publicly
right now to the Press
this is not correct it will not be
enforced the citizens have a right to
keep in bear arms you know as as
regulated and we will not
arrest anyone I'm sorry I've seen it
happen 20 times we all know uh the story
a story that I heard about it's actually
a relatively prominent a woman from
Pennsylvania was going to Atlantic City
she had a revolver in her purse she gets
she crosses the bridge into Jersey
and gets pulled over officer comes and
says you know I pulled you over and she
goes I don't and then she says but I do
want to let you in just keep make sure
you're informed I I do have my my weapon
oh my my gun on me I do have a permit
for it and it's here in my bag anyway
thank you ma'am out of the vehicle
please you're under arrest that's a
felony and wow the only reason uh so
this is a story that was told to me by a
gun shop in New Jersey
apparently it was a big deal the only
reason she got off was that her lawyers
pulled up a a a a case where a celebrity
was given a special pass what's her name
I don't know I don't know the woman's
name is I was in a gun shop this guy
told me so if I heard the story too like
I I can they were they were terrified
that this story has gone around right
there was some celebrity who got a
special treatment their lawyer cited
this case and then the D.A was like okay
drop it drop it drop it we're gonna lose
this one it's gonna set bad precedent
but the only thing that matters to me is
that the cop with a smile on his face
said ma'am I know the bridge is five
minutes right there I could turn you
around right now and say just bring it
home but I want to destroy you instead
he decided I'm going to ruin your life
right like so I'm like there's a lot of
people that are a cab and there's a lot
of people that are very oh don't cross
The Thin Blue Line both positions are
stupid all right you have to have some
amount of policing in your in your
society and in your community and if you
go to communities that are riddled with
crime and you talk to the normal people
that are not committing crimes they're
like send more cops we need more police
be because we need to get these people
that are committing the crimes off the
streets if you go to places that are
high crime the police know the people
that are committing the crimes they can
pick them out usually it's a you know if
it's a major city a couple hundred
couple few hundred or whatever you could
lock those people up and that'll solve a
large portion of the crime that doesn't
mean that every time a cop pulls you
over it's a good idea to tell them all
your personal private in information
concealed is concealed hush if a cop
pulls you over I think you have to tell
about your gun you have to tell about
your gun I I think they are trying to
create
physical conflict in this country
there's look these videos of the feds
arresting j6ers with rifles pointed at
them some like portly fellow walks out
of his house in his shorts like
scratching his face like huh and they're
just all pointing rifles what happened
in Provo Utah when they went in that
guy's house shot and killed him
it it appears maybe it's not the case
but it certainly appears like they are
doing everything they're possible to
provoke a violent outbreak this right
here in New Mexico is basically chucking
Dynamite into a crowd and being like
let's see what happens
yeah I know a lot of like the case that
you were talking about earlier where
like the the copy said actively chose
they made that decision to ruin her life
or at least make her life extremely
difficult for the next few years that
that's where like I've learned a lot uh
just being around like you know donut
operator Cody uh like my best friend
he's great I've learned a lot about
policing and different stuff like that
through his eyes and stuff like that and
a big thing that he harps on is Officer
discretion with stuff like that like
that that's something that and I think
that's where a lot of the Nuance gets
lost between like the acab crowd The
Thin Blue Line crowd like the officer is
always wrong the officer is always right
like officer discretion is really an
important thing that is not utilized
enough and I know that there's a lot of
officers a lot of police officers that
don't live in the towns that they that
they police and I understand that
there's a lot of security issues that
can come up and and their safety issues
if you're if you're in a place that's
got a lot of crime and you're actively
throwing people in jail and you live in
that town then there's a possibility of
Retribution and stuff I get it but if
you have police officers that you see
regularly and you know you can have a
rapport with them and the police
officers can have a rapport with you if
a cop knows that you're not one of the
handful of of garbage cans that are out
there causing all kinds of problems in
town the cop should and I obviously it's
not every cop but the cop really should
take that into consideration so shout
out to Elon Musk uh for helping bring
awareness to this he he just responded
but it's all like his response is
already generating a reactions to the
the story I tweeted the story out holy F
uh and so a whole bunch of people have
have jumped on it that's what gives me
hope is that the this this was such a
bold and psychotic move it's like
dropping a boulder into a pond everyone
notices the bang and the massive Splash
just just shot them and the cops the New
Mexico State cops that are listening
right now or they're going to hear this
story have an opportunity to exercise
some discretion right now you got to
protect your citizens yeah I mean
especially if you you swore an oath to
the constitution of not only the United
States but I imagine to New Mexico so
that's their obligation and there's and
you know you mentioned the constitution
of New Mexico I'm sorry to cut you often
real quick but like almost every state
in the Union has something that
resembles the Second Amendment all of
them
every single one has something similar
it's not the exact same thing but all of
them have something like the Second
Amendment because owning firearms
is one of the things that is a clear
indication that you are free right
California doesn't have one
and it is daily they must have you well
actually I don't know they never really
did it's a newer State relative to the
rest of them but yeah so maybe Hawaii
doesn't as well but you know like
seriously it's like the the Second
Amendment is supposed to be you know
Supremacy Clauses means that it's
supposed to be the supreme law but you
know so man you know we're the culture
War this morning was was very
interesting uh I thought it was pretty
good
poor Alex didn't really get a chance to
speak didn't really speak so I can't
really you know thanks for coming anyway
buddy but uh Brandon Wu is here and the
general sentiment among many of these
leftists one thing I love what they do
is they take tweets of mine where I say
something like Civil War but they remove
the context of why I said it so it's
just a bunch of tweets that blankets say
Civil War whatever but it'll be like I
don't know there'll be an article that
says something the effect of far left
extremists you know opens fire killing
so and so and I'll be like Civil War and
then they'll remove that story and just
snip the little statement and then imply
that I'm insinuating that there's some
kind of uh or that I want to happen
quite the opposite
but uh in our conversation
every single time it comes up someone
will say to me touch grass right as the
old meme go talk to regular people and
my response is just
do you think that during like the first
the American Civil War that some dude
walked out of his house in Atlanta
looked at his neighbor and said do you
want Civil War and then the other guy
went I certainly do ah let's fight
now if you lived in New York and you
lived in in Atlanta you'd walk outside
and no one's talking about it because
your life was different you were focused
on your farm or your shop or your the
the the the the minutiae and routine of
your daily lives
everyone seems to think that you need a
mass mobilization of half the country
rising up and formally declaring
hostilities against the other half and
that's never been the case in this
instance the reason why this story is
alarming we've just quite literally been
talking about Lexington and Concord over
the past week when a couple hundred
Redcoats were like hand over your guns
and they were like not you know you can
pry for my cold dead hands
and then they tried
and that's considered a handful of
militiamen maybe it's a hyperbox a
handful but local militiamen regular
people who bought who had weapons saying
no was the first battle of the American
Revolution the shot heard around the
world and and to even further your point
like going back to the American Civil
War after the you know you've got the
revolution with Lexington Lexington and
Concord but in the American or in the uh
the American Civil War uh there's always
usually a focal point that happens and
it's usually some sort of government
decree of some sort because uh the one
in the American Civil War a lot of
people point to is when Lincoln uh went
to the South and he went to a lot of
Southern States and said I expect you to
send me 75 000 troops so we can go
invade the states in Rebellion yep which
is it was like I think he demanded a
North Carolina and a few others and the
in the response was overwhelmingly I
think we're gonna secede instead yeah so
a lot of people always get mad when we
talk about the stuff they're like you're
not a historian and you're getting facts
wrong it's like okay dude I read I read
a couple academic historical papers and
watch a few documentaries so I'm
probably wrong but the general my
general understanding was that sevens I
think it was seven states seceded before
Lincoln was inaugurated and then you had
States I think it was like uh Tennessee
West Virginia
um
uh Virginia well not West Virginia but
Virginia itself because there was no
West Virginia Virginia was like you know
we kind of want us to seed but we
probably shouldn't and they're like okay
so we're not gonna then Lincoln said hey
these states an active Rebellion I'm
gonna conscript troops to go quell that
rebellion and that shifted sentiment in
these states to where they were like
okay now you want us to go to war okay
this is this has gone too far where we
want us to go to war with our neighbor
yeah yeah it was like not not go to war
with Canada or Britain or France or
whatever like you want us to go to war
with like the state that we border right
are you are you crazy but this this
shifted sentiment but I do think it's
fair to say that's that's actually we're
we're so far away from that Bleeding
Kansas is a better example of where we
may be today and the American Revolution
may have better uh analogs or the
Spanish Civil War but uh Bleeding Kansas
was a seven year conflict that not even
just Kansas but in the territories
outside of the actual States the US
territories with the debate over which
state would be a slave state or not you
had people murdering each other so
I look at this
history doesn't repeat it rhymes
what happens today will not be a
one-for-one reflection of what happened
back then because the internet I mean
that's that's the easy one things are
very different
I have I in in look man you know I'm
talking to Brianna Wu earlier and she's
saying like we need to stop being in
each other's necks calm down and you
know move this country forward
everything they're doing
does nothing but escalate and I mean the
establishment the machine the doj let's
I won't even take Democrats I'll say the
doj when you have Joe Biggs get 19 and a
half years in prison
for for this stuff I'm like yeah you
realize that's just going to make
everyone angrier
they like to say that it's absurd to
bring up the concept of Civil War so I
asked a few simple questions of Brianna
do you think the people that uh stormed
the capital when Joe Biden wins in 2024
will just pet their heads and say well
good game everybody we're done or do you
think they just say we are still angry
angry enough to break into the Capitol
Building there's there's been no logical
assessment by anyone trying who has
takes issue with Barbara Walter Stephen
Marsh or I there's been no logical
argument against anything we've said and
these are those are two Democrats I'm
citing specifically who have said more
so than I that we are we are we are in
or actively facing Civil War there's
been no argument as to what the off-ramp
would be
foreign
that goes back to like the classic meme
of like who radicalized you you did
it's like it's it's those it's those
it's it's the actions of those people
that because they're just they they're
it's a lot of it's almost a direct
comparison to what you know people like
Jordan Peterson had said about Ukraine
right we need to figure out what victory
is because it's like you know is winning
a good thing in in the long run it's
like if do you want to if you rub your
nose in the cat piss is that really
winning long term are you just building
resentment are you making things worse
that's and I look at what the doj is
doing
a video is just put up I think it was
Julie Kelly of Enrique tario on the day
of January 6. with her he's being filmed
they were filming this and he had no
idea they got in the building he was
surprised to see it and the evidence is
all there this is a fabrication against
him uh according to her tweet the feds
tried to get Enrique to say that he was
working with Trump or that Trump had
some involvement they wanted to connect
Trump directly to Proud boys so they can
put a brand name on Insurrection and say
Trump orchestrated it likely to remove
his name from the ballot Enrique refused
so they give him 22 years plus it'll be
22 and a half
you know what I said
there is something Joe Biden can do if
you want to simmer things down he can
issue a blanket pardon of all the of all
J sixes right now and he can say like
Shay's Rebellion he can say it was wrong
of what you did but we cannot survive as
a nation if we're constantly at each
other's throats that's why I think it's
fair to say for those that have spent
time already time served and for
everyone else we are giving you a good
faith effort they won't well they might
that's we gotta make sure that we don't
go so far as to say that the solution
won't happen you have to propose a
solution and allow it to hang
so I get what you're saying that that's
that's probably a good perspective to
have um that being said it will take
Democrats to stop the escalation like
Republicans can't like Republicans and
the people that are being persecuted by
the Democrats by the The Establishment
they're not in a position to say okay
we're gonna go ahead and chill things
out and the reason is because all of the
things that they're accused of are all
things that are legal like they they
fabricate stuff the guy that from
Infowars that's gonna go to jail
he was speaking like
tario was talking to people right and
these aren't it wasn't incite and it is
such these are such tortured accusations
and they have to be stretched and
twisted so much to make them fit it's
ridiculous and because of that it has to
be the the people that are in the
position of power saying okay we're
going to stop using our power because
the people that are not in positions of
Power are not in any position to say
we're going to stop escalating because
they're not the ones escalating exactly
Tim you brought it up Bonnie Williams
actually refused to indict these people
so that's an example of someone in power
not taking the next step here's a story
from timcast.com Fulton County Special
grand jury voted to indict Lindsey
Graham and two other GOP senators
wow the special grand jury in Fulton
County Georgia recommended charges
against former president Trump agent of
Associates as well as South Carolina
Republican senator Lindsey Graham as
well as Georgia Georgia Republican
Senators David Perdue and Kelly loffler
it is only because I don't I think it
doesn't serve the political ends of the
democratic party that they overlooked
these elements of these individuals in
the indictment
for what purpose are they going to go
after these individuals is it going to
help them remove Trump no they would
have Trump staff and his lawyers
here's what matters
it brings up a good point the D.A did
not take that step
however I push back on this the D.A took
the most extreme step of arresting Trump
and Trump's lawyers
this shows the political nature of the
indictments what if if the grand jury
said these people as well as the other
18 plus Trump
should be indicted and finally goes not
these three it shows you that everything
she's doing is purely political it also
shows you in these districts it doesn't
matter what is true a grand jury will
indict sitting members of the Senate
if asked to
that is the sentiment of touching grass
this is the funny thing about when
people say oh go touch grass like you
mean like a grand jury that tried to
indict three Republican members of the
Senate those are those are regular
people that are that are called in for
jury duty are given evidence and said
would you criminally charge members of
of the Senate they said absolutely
so you want to go talk to regular people
I'm telling you man
people are ready people are angry and of
course it's never going to be
90 or 80 but I think the American
Revolution was the colloquial term was a
third for a third against and a third
don't care it's actually more like
closer to 40 percent were in favor of
closer to like 20 some odd percent were
opposed and the uh uh the plurality was
like we just don't care at all if we
were going to have if there's gonna be
an American Revolution too it would just
be like the Constitution is written so
that we can revolve the laws and create
an internal Revolution without having to
overthrow the government so like it
would be a technical Revolution which
we're kind of seeing with the internet
but like uh it would be like an attack
it would be a change in the system it
was it doesn't have to be it could be
cool it was naive of the founding
fathers to assume that men in power
would agree to give it up because it was
written on a piece of paper
I don't know I I think that's a bit of
an overstatement that they that they
were unaware that men uh well
considering the statements of Thomas
Jefferson I'm I I know like they were
very serious about what happens to
countries uh although it is it is true
that Jefferson walked that back the tree
of Liberty statement and said it's a
little bit too egregious
um because that's pre-war talk it's a
well no it's also pretty specific on a
time frame which is a little
you saw what happened in France right
because like what year did he say that
oh sorry I'm not sure exactly what Yuri
said it but the point is like the friend
the French Revolution that happened like
right around it started like right
around or after the 1807 yes like so and
they were you know there were Americans
that were going over there and and
talking to the French because they were
there was all this talk of Liberty and
stuff the French Revolution was 1789.
yeah it was an S show all right it was a
total Constitution
not a coincidence within a couple years
they just started killing everybody the
the word terrorism comes from the French
Revolution the terror is what they
called it up and that was just slaying
people for the the horrible crime of not
being Rogue enough spear went full
Mickey Mouse Fantasia dancing people to
the guillotine one by one psychos and it
was it was nuts and so anyway this is
what people need to understand about
things like this
a grand jury voted to indict these men
the D.A decided not to do it the D.A
went after the president and his lawyers
so the D.A took a more Extreme Action
and I think it shows as I stated earlier
this is political the important factor
here is that it shows that regular
people also want to see these things
done
that's what people need to understand
about where this goes and I will say it
right now
there is one strong action that can be
taken to stop it all a couple actually
first the indictments against Trump
should be dropped and Joe Biden should
pardon the January Sixers
and that is how when you're trying to
resolve a conflict you have to be the
one to make the compromise and that
would take so much of the wind out of
the sales of the current Trump campaign
and the entire right at the moment like
I I don't I seriously don't think it's
ever going to happen because they're
exacerbating I mean these personalities
are saying more and more and more no
matter what yeah would you do the same
would you pardon Joe Biden Hunter Biden
I didn't say I didn't say Joe Biden I'm
asking if you would because like you
said you have to be the first one to
make the the first move if you want to
end this conflict would you be the one
to do that it so let's let's slow down
and talk about the specifics of
charges against Trump over January 6th
and the people on January 6. if Joe
Biden and Hillary Clinton were
criminally charged and the Democratic
party the DNC over the Steele dossier
and those moves that were made against
Trump with russiagate I would I would
sit down with me personally and say
all of that goes away
we're done and the j6 stuff is done and
we start here and we try and figure it
out I see it like that I see it as a it
has to be not the connection stuff it
can't be like even barisma no I don't
think you can get a prisoner exchange
without offering a pardon to to uh Joe
Biden and Hunter Biden and Hillary like
think of it as a prisoner exchange if
you can't find compassion and do it
because you just want you think it's a
good move think of it as like we're
trading victims here to try to end this
is it with a white piece does that
require them getting into some sort of
legal trouble in the first place right
the issue is there there's nothing to
drop as of right now that with Hillary
well you preemptively partner for this
email Scandal having Sydney Blumenthal
having him set up Osprey Global
Solutions what's the point of of
pardoning Hillary Clinton when she
wasn't even Prosecuting like there's a
guarantee that she won't be prosecuted
in the future
there's no chance that she's getting
prosecuted well I think they feel like
if Trump gets into office they'll all
get prosecuted I don't think Hillary
will get prosecuted but a lot of people
are gonna he didn't if she didn't get
prosecuted the first time he was in
office like if it wasn't happening then
it's it's well I don't know Trump is
maybe about to go scorched nah I'm not
saying that I don't want Hillary Clinton
to get prosecuted either like I hear
your argument and I totally disagree I
want to put all those sons of in
jail so that's just me though and there
there lies the challenge they want to
put all the j-sexes in jail yeah and the
only way we move forward right now is
for one there are no charges against
democrats for everything they did with
Russia gate and steel dossier so it's a
moot point they would need to lay down
their attacks and say we're gonna chill
out right now and give a little and stop
attacking so much the fact that they're
doing anything
there's nothing for the Republicans to
stop doing right now right now we say
like hey there's current active
hostilities in in law fair
we're asking the Democrats stop
the Republicans haven't done anything so
you know next question
yeah have they have they filed criminal
charges against any of the Democrats
over the steel dossier
nothing over anything related to
russiagating those lies
has anyone done a deep investigation
into uh what would happen with Ukraine
gate and and and uh collusion between
government and the private and private
law to go after Trump force a version of
our of our government was our sedition
charge nothing
so all that's happening now is
yeah we're not throwing any Stones over
here we're asking you to stop if they
don't then that that I look man it's not
about what should happen What should
happen is an election happens in 2024
the right person for the job wins and
everybody says okay well you know we'll
try again next time that brings up an
interesting question I think do you
think there ever will be charges brought
in the future uh over what's going on in
Ukraine right now as far as like the
Biden involvements
really okay well well I'll put it this
way I believe that there is a
probability it happens if Trump wins
outside of that no and that could be 17
you know what I mean right I bet Joe
Biden will pardon Hunter the day before
he leaves office oh yeah of course he'll
pardon Hunter and Hillary he might
pardon a bunch of them yep of course he
will that's that's what so that's why
you that's why we got to Pardon him
first that's my point they're gonna I
missed the entertaining days when the
president would just pardon rappers and
yeah well Trump dead if they're
Untouchable like play the game be like
okay you're untouchable the issue right
now I agree if they are going after
Donald Trump in his first term to
falsely accuse him of being a Russian
spy and then you're the whole time
saying just pardon him for doing it it's
like yo you've got someone who's
shoved you up against the wall and put a
blade to your neck and then you said you
know the only way out of this is if I
allow you to do it sounds like Alex
Stein you're talking about actually they
pulled a knife on me on a show one time
oh no I didn't know that yeah I'm saying
that the Democrats
yeah it was a joke but it was a real
knife the Democrats have been engaged
hostilities against the but I forgot it
was right since Trump got elected and
the right has done nothing except for
January maybe I'm crazy man I I don't
know if we're in the end I don't know if
this is like Revelation if the Bible's
real if forgiveness is actually valuable
or if we're just tricked into thinking
that kindness compassion and forgiveness
is but it has to come from the people
committing the acts it's only good in
society Trump supporters have done
nothing since Trump got elected if you
only live is like we're only going to
get past this if you apologize
we apologize for yeah what that's it's a
blanket it's for everything they ever
did for what I'm apologizing for
Hillary's crimes before she has to but
you submitted a bunch of serious crimes
and continue to wage lawfare against us
while we sit back and do nothing but
we're going to apologize to you this is
how you end up dead this is how
okay oh okay so then just give up
everything I mean what the the way to
end up dead is by suggesting a pardon by
constantly laying down and saying hey
it's okay if you rain piss on us dude
what's your I mean what's the optional
solution then the option is is
soothe the absolute hell out of everyone
that violates your rights
Trump wins through so Trump lost by 42
000 votes that's that's in safe it's
Trump
by 42 000 votes zero points did you
tally the votes yourself how do you know
that that number was accurate they give
you a little bit they give you a little
piece like it was 51.49 don't worry
about it you got it you guys this is the
most something I definitely don't
believe vote tallies without seeing the
code of the machine okay but now you're
making different arguments that aren't
aren't the 40 I'm sorry part of the
conversation if Donald Trump lost by 42
000 votes across three states then the
best course of action right now is
ballot harvesting voter registration and
political rallying commercials Etc but I
don't agree with the if I don't believe
that he won by 42 000 votes I just
haven't seen the proof me and show me
the data and the code
I believe that proprietary companies own
our voting machine so you think you
think they stole it from Trump by
hacking voting machines I think that it
is undeterminable and I'm not going to
believe one or the other unless I see
the proof one way or the other so this
is the way it works your options right
now are to be trampled and have your
rights stolen from you and destroyed to
try to vote to win
pick one
these these false binaryism
what are you suggesting are you
advocating for non for not voting is
that the what what do you I guess are
you advocating for so I can understand
well I my point is that we're thinking
that Trump's gonna win is like a fantasy
then you know what you're saying
do you know what you are saying I'm just
saying that I don't trust the way the
votes are tallied in this country you
are saying they will not allow a
peaceful Revolution
it doesn't matter if it's likely or not
the only course of action is every legal
method to secure votes for Donald Trump
in the hopes
he takes action towards weeding out deep
State corruption cleaning up the doj so
what's even further than that something
I would like to see that is a huge
frustration for me because everybody's
talking you know everybody's caught up
in the conversation of whether or not
the election was stolen what what really
drives me crazy is that there's concrete
evidence of uh just different places
where you know poll Watchers are kicked
out and and there's there's actual fraud
when it comes to ballot counting all
sorts of stuff and none of those people
have been held accountable people making
tick tocks and all sorts of stuff like
those people like if their feet aren't
being held to the fire then what is well
let's let's say this there are there is
a preponderance of evidence
of fraud occurring in several instances
to the degree we don't actually know
because the courts never adjudicated
them absolutely there should be an
inquiry and an adjudication however it's
funny when you know uh I I don't think
Trump lost because of like fake ballots
or flipping votes and voting machines I
think that Democrats outright said what
they did in the shadow campaign article
for Time magazine that they had Mass
about harvesting operations that
Governors changed the voting rules in
violation of the Constitution and then
when the state legislature said hey we
have a question about this they said too
bad so it's a procedural question not a
fraud question do they allow ballot
harvesting and they did when in many
states it was legal in some states it
was not my point is only this
conflict crisis and violence is not
winning
violence erupting in this country is a
defeat of anybody
if anything ends up happening where a
fight breaks out every time a fight
breaks out or violence breaks out
between the left and the right
everyone's lost when January 6 happened
Trump and and everyone on the right took
a strategic defeat even on the left
everybody lost that day the what a
horrible misuse of justice and
politically the right lost
a tremendous deal
all we can say right now is
you are standing on a sheet of ice
and it may be difficult to cross and it
may be unlikely but the only thing you
can try and do is walk the The Edge and
try and make it to the other side
we are hoping that there is a path
forward through legitimate legal
electoral means and it seems to be based
on all the data coming out right now
that's the case it appears that what
they're doing by indicting Trump and his
lawyers and arresting the j6ers and
decreeing guns are illegal is a panicked
desperate attempt to create some kind of
shock content where they can muster up
something for 2024. Bud Light Target
sound of Freedom Richmond north of
Richmond the cultural victories are in
the billions yeah man private sector
that's where it's at but that is
reflected in the electorate with Joe
Biden's numbers on the decline and
collapsing you do not get 30 billion
dollars lost on Bud Light and no
reflection in politics of course the
people who stopped drinking Bud Light
are voting for Trump
there's there's there's there's look if
you come to me and said
here's a guy who boycotted Bud Light
over the Dome of anything do you think
he's voting for Trump and no
circumstance would I ever make a bet
that person would vote against Trump but
if you look at the massive moves that
were made against Target Disney Netflix
Bud Light all of this is indicative of a
populist
massive populist movement being
successful
and the reason Republicans lose in 2020
they do as well in in Congress and they
didn't do uh and they win the presidency
is because the Democrats procedurally
outplayed them use a Russell Malin
voting what do you think about
unquestionable uh the 2022 election
though the the Congressional elections
the Republicans did not bound Harvest
they did not engage with with how the
Democrats were handling Universal mail
and voters that was something that that
Trump did really well objectively in
2016. was the way that they targeted
like you know uh mail-in voting and
early voting and all sorts of stuff that
was it was a real shift for the
Republican party is to to focus on that
in the campaign and they didn't do it in
2020 which is mind-blowing I think it's
like four to one Democrat ground
activism versus Republican ground
activism yeah then you add in the fact
that Democrats live next to each other
and in suburbs you have houses lined up
whereas in rural areas where
conservatives live the houses are far
apart meaning two Democrats can hit a
hundred houses in an hour and two
Republicans can hit 15. that is the
advantage of the Democrats in creating
Universal mail and voting it was a
procedural shift it was the bulk of how
they pulled it off and Trump only needs
42 000 in these key States so why are
they indicting him in Georgia they are
panicked and desperate and need to get
his name off the bat because they can't
win
so everyone needs to recognize that the
one thing they're hoping for why are
they decreeing guns illegal they are
desperately hoping that someone gets
violent
about that the real quick on the guns
being the declaring guns illegal they
used a public health announcement and
that was the I think that something that
occurred to me that's the same
justification they used for violating
everybody's rights over covet of course
so now the precedent so the the the
covid stuff has now become precedent to
violate your rights we saw this coming
yeah I mean it is but now we now we're
seeing it actually start to material
because you could really see where that
was the where the excitement was
building they're like oh wow these
people will just roll over and let us do
anything as long as we call it a Public
Health crisis as long as they say it's
good the Germans the Nazis did that too
they were bringing Eugenics group
exercise warning against alcohol and
tobacco is a lot about public health I
don't know how How Deeply they took that
even the Nazi verbiage uh when they were
talking about you know Jewish people or
whatever like that they were they were
talking about it as like a plague an
epidemic like they used a lot of just
the way that they talked about it their
dictionary in that way was very
reflective of a public health incident
yeah when they start calling people
elements or like dangerous elements yep
yeah and and that's already happening to
conservatives you know you know the the
way that they have now again people are
gonna go freak out and be like Oh Phil's
making comparisons to World War II and
blah blah and that's not my point but
because it's not just World War II
there's all kinds of places where you
have one group of people demonizing
another people in order to get the
the population more broadly to hate on
the the people they're demonizing so you
can apply it to World War II but you can
also apply to a bunch of other contexts
throughout history it's not exclusively
something that's happened uh you know in
World War II but it works you you had
Hillary Clinton uh you know declaring
all of the Trump supporters throwing him
into the basket of deplorables and since
then and it was probably it was starting
beforehand but since then like when she
made that comment that's really when it
started to coalesce that people that
were outside of the Democrat
establishment that were acceptable that
had the acceptable opinions if you're
outside of that then you are outside of
of our democracy and you are to be
ignored and marginalized as much as they
want and now they're using the
government to clamp down on people for
having the wrong political which is
something I think Trump did better than
anybody else like the deplorable thing
and everything like he takes like his
mug shot for example if you take
something that they think is going to be
a gotcha something that they try to use
against him and he just twists it
masterfully like the man is a marketer
didn't they do a an event called the
deplora ball I was there people danced
and stuff what was it no it's like uh it
was a at the Press Club in DC and so you
walked around eating hors d'oeuvres
talking to people yeah master of market
and uh Cassandra made uh I think little
Keck frog statues to give away or
something like that it was it was it was
and antifusted outside throwing uh rocks
and bottles at random people should do
that stuff again has licked one of their
faces should do that not in DC you
should do it in a place where you can
carry guns well you think about DC is
that if you're a far left terrorist
who's violently attacking you know old
conservatives who are going to a a
building for a private event the police
won't stop you yeah the police did not
arrest as far as I know no these people
got arrested for physically attacking
people the police donors arrest leftists
that are doing stuff to conservatives if
the leftists are doing stuff to like
police or if they're making a noise you
might get arrested but if you're left is
attacking the right they don't arrest
you I mean the entire Summer of Love 100
you you look at these people like these
antifa people that are throwing
essentially makeshift bombs IED
something that would be registered as a
destructive device in any other context
yeah throwing them at you know
government buildings and then the next
day their bail is paid and then nothing
ever happens that's that point that you
just made that would be a destructive
device that's 10 years literally any
other context every single thing that
they were throwing at the the Federal
Building in any other context would have
to get an NFA approval you'd have to go
ahead and have fingerprints and your uh
your uh
password photo taken and then you have
to be registered with the federal
government and they were throwing them
and it's a 200 tax payment 10 years for
God that's 10 years and quarter million
dollar fine and I do know for a fact
because I was there for some of it
during some of the riots there were ATF
on the ground they're investigating some
of that stuff nothing ever came of it of
course not because it wasn't politically
you know because they had to get the
braces oh of course yeah of course the
braces were the real problems
cocktails being thrown into 250 year old
buildings it wasn't the literal
communist revolutionaries that were
throwing Molotov cocktails and firebombs
at the Federal Building you had to get
the braces because it if that had been
handled properly would it have been like
the executive Trump the president would
have issued like National Guard I mean
it was a state would have had like
National Guard if they're if they're
firebombing or attacking a federal
building what was the Federal no it was
when they went out there well that
because they were there it was the ATF
it was the ATF yeah the ATF was there
like uh what was it Portland wherever
the Federal
it was an amalgam of federal law
enforcement agencies so you had ice you
had CBP you had FPS even in the local
ones like where I was at at the time in
Fayetteville uh they they had there was
Molotov cocktail that was thrown into uh
the market house there like in downtown
because I think that was where George
Floyd's family was from if I'm not
mistaken it's an old building from the
1700s and uh ATF was there the next day
investigating nothing ever came of it
and technically that is something that
is supposed to be an NFA registered item
but of course nothing ever comes of it
because that's not politically prudent I
think that the uh the left wants the
conflict so they can use it as a pretext
for removing the Constitution that uh
there are there are people on the left
that do I don't I don't know I'm not
going to say that it's the the your
average Democrat I think your average
Democrat is actually a uh uh useful
idiot The Medallion of evil yeah they're
helping because they're idiots and
because they don't pay attention but yes
there is definitely I mean there there
is a we're in the middle of a cultural
Evolution right now these fights that
we're having this the culture war that
we're having it is a cultural revolution
you can't say that we are in a culture
War but say no we're not in a cultural
revolution because there's that same
thing
yeah they really are uh when Brianna Wu
was on the culture War
she said that's what's happening with
the j6ers
holistically is the right direction
and I said the proud boys got two
decades is that is that justified and
her position was I did not look at those
specific stories but I think generally
it's good and I said that is the
banality of evil the question of how do
how do evil acts become commonplace
because the average person just assumes
it's fine or it's the right thing
without looking at the individuals who
are having their rights violated there
is no circumstance in any sane person's
mind where you knock over a temporary
barricade and you get 20 you get 19 and
a half years in prison
there is no circumstance in the same
person's mind where you aren't even
there
and they give you 22 years only people
who did not pay attention to these cases
and don't care or are tribally satisfied
by destroying the lives of other people
would want these things to be the case
I'll take it a step further there's
people that I know that I've talked to
that uh think that even just being there
because I've talked about a couple cases
that I knew of just you know uh
allegorically that were not even in the
capital they didn't even get into the
capital but they were just there at what
later became the January 6th that
they're trying to turn in the next 9 11.
uh that were then investigated by the
FBI and and were given a temporary ban
from DC and a bunch of other stuff and
people have argued in favor of that
they're like yeah well they were there
they they should have known what that
would become and what and I'm over here
thinking like you are
literally there to listen to the then
sitting president of the United States
speak well there there are people who
got uh but from their jobs simply
because they were in DC on January 6
nowhere near the capital well what's
crazy is that that even even if you were
there even if you were listening to
Trump speak there who's you know well
but let's clarify Trump was not speaking
at the Capitol right right no no not at
the Capitol but there but they're in DC
at a protest that is literally the first
amendment is your right to peaceably
assemble that is the first amendment in
the Bill of Rights like that is that is
a very constitutionally protected action
and people are advocating well well they
should have known
yeah I I fully believe that they should
have been targeted for that like that
blows my mind that people are even
making that argument yeah there are
people who lost their jobs because they
were at the ellipse listening to Trump
speak and then went home and then people
were like whoa you were in DC during
January 6th don't know don't care so
there are a lot of people who are in DC
on that date who did not go anywhere
near the capital who have had social
repercussions just for that
it just seems to me
I don't know man
there's no there's no logical argument
against
this getting worse
and it's an unfortunate thing I would
much prefer to just play Magic the
Gathering all day play poker all day
then go skateboarding play some music
and not be involved in anything like
this it'd be much better if I if I did
one video per day where I was like here
are the new polling numbers Donald Trump
wants to increase taxes on Imports oh
last night everyone chills but instead I
was gonna message you and be like I just
said a figure Italian person if we win
the culture War it's going to happen in
Baldur's Gate
you mean like we're gonna win a video
game but the rest of the world just
burns well what I meant was we'll be
streaming online we'll have 100 million
people watching or something like that
like 10 million people will watch us
stream a video game and like see the
humanity in us and like then the
politics will become evident and obvious
if they like you they believe you yeah
the problem is I disagree there are
people like you're not there's never
going to be a degree of influence like
that again
uh because the way the internet operates
I don't know you got guys like Elon you
got I don't know in fact you maybe
you're right but in a way you kind of it
might be greater than it ever has been
in the history of humanity the way that
one human can rally the rest with the
internet I don't necessarily know if
it's one human but I do like the idea
that now you have the entire information
gathering source is open source uh for
the first time so you're not relying on
Walter Cronkite for what America
believes it's it's very uh well
distributed now so like there there is a
chance like that but I don't think it's
going to be one person but yeah it would
be it wouldn't be one individual one
person's always the tip of the spear and
then it's just but they're a result of
their Community yeah and but really what
that meant that the culture will be one
in Baldur's Gate is that if we continue
to try and find a political solution to
the military-industrial complex it will
lead us down to failure there's no
there's no political there's no way to
take power away I mean you need to
inspire the masses and I think that's
done through cultural Endeavor
scientific Endeavor TV shows arts and
entertainment and then you get these six
nine nine-year-olds by the time they're
20 they're ready to make something great
they already know they've been thinking
about it their whole lives and they know
how to do it do you need to inspire the
masses or do you need to inspire the
five percent of people on the fence that
aren't doing anything it's fractal so
you only need to inspire a small amount
that then will inspire small amounts
that will inspire small amounts that
like it fractals out so you as an
individual probably only need to inspire
about a hundred thousand people maybe 80
000 people probably the best case I've
ever seen for that was Ron Paul like the
the ramifications of what Ron Paul did
thank you
created a generation of
uh of populists of libertarian
populist types I look at so many of the
people who today we talk with who come
on the show and they're all like
whatever their political views are
they're like I used to watch a lot of
run Paul
that movement back in 2008 was more
influential I I I bet you've got unit
party Democrats Republicans sitting
around the room being like if we just
had a time machine we'd go back and we
would not let Ron Paul anywhere near the
presidential elections
yeah he was very good and Mike Revel I
thought those guys were they were you
ended up with only a few years later
after Obama the left and right-wing
populist Uprising for which Bernie is
too weak to maintain and caved and
Donald Trump who kicked the doors and
the corporations are like let's profit
and the CCP is like let's control let's
manipulate create tick tock
spam their children
it's fascinating to me one of the one of
the converse one of the uh talking
points that we had earlier with the
culture War was
I was asked if I thought the
intelligence agency should be destroyed
and I said that like almost all of them
should be fired in government there
needs to become some kind of like
civilian oversight audit of all of these
systems and a termination and a
restructuring you know because
I I am not the anarchist libertarian
shut it all down overnight just ban
everything I know Thomas Massey is like
no more doe I'm more alike you know
audit termination or maybe even
immediate termination then audit and
then assessment and restructuring or
dismissal
but uh I can't think of a better formula
for rot in DC oh yeah than a federal
agency that by definition
cannot expose its dealings to the public
that just seems like a breeding ground
for really bad stuff but I said that the
intelligent age intelligence agencies
were abject evil and I was like I don't
understand anyone especially on the left
or democrat after everything they've
done and we know they've done would sit
here and be like no they're good and
necessary the NSA well we know all about
The Clapper lying to Congress and the
mass spying they're doing the FBI should
we bring up Martin Luther King Jr but
the interesting thing is
what we're told by the left is climate
change is bad the oceans ever since have
acidified if the trees are being torn
down the world is on fire and it is the
fault of us and these corporations
by the way they're being propped up by
the U.S intelligence apparatus going to
war around the world to maintain the
Petro dollar and then I have people come
in here and say but they're doing good
work and I'm like not by your own logic
if you want all of these bad things if
you think America is bad fundamentally
racist Mass polluting and needs to stop
well then why would you agree with the
intelligence apparatus maintaining all
these things by like you know why would
you agree with you as military securing
oil in Syria with with soldiers you'd be
like oil's bad stop sending our soldiers
overseas to guard it
but they don't they have this it's a
contradictory worldview of we we like
the war in Ukraine for gas and oil and
we like International conflict but we'll
pretend sometimes that we don't
uh it's like conflict resolution I think
that's part of the psyche of the human
is desire to overcome some sort of
conflict like build self-esteem I find
it in video games you know probably
people find it with their kids probably
I don't have kids but like what do you
how do you find your conflict resolution
working out helps me too sounds like
you're talking about the power principle
that that uh
uncle Ted was talking about Ted
Kaczynski yeah no what is it do you ever
read you ever read the manifesto so I
actually real quick before on that I I
was shocked at the lack of uh
I guess inspiration that his death led
to I I immediately saw him like oh Ted
Kaczynski died I'm like and it's very
public like that's gonna lead to a
massive rise in people reading that book
and realizing yeah Uncle Teddy K had
some points you know I know that's
that's the scary thing is uh sticks
hacks and Hammer made a really great
point a while ago we're on a panel uh
someone tried quoting some like white
nationalist guy and then uh my response
was why you know why are you bringing up
a white nationalist in the conversation
and his his views and then stick said
yeah the guys got bad views but let's
not discount an accurate quote because a
bad person said it and I'm like I
completely agree with that I just my
view was kind of like I think that
person's trying to Goat us into jumping
into their you know conversation about
Israel but Styx made a really great
point in that a lot of really bad people
said a lot of really important things
you know what I mean and it's like
it like Hitler Hitler like dogs you know
what I mean if if you you need to make
sure that you're discarding and
challenging all the really dark and evil
things but you don't immediately assume
everything is always going to be dark
and evil because then we'd all be like
liking dogs is bad because it makes you
like Hitler same thing with good people
like Martin Luther King was a womanizer
but you don't don't shred his meaningful
message because he slept around and
cheated on his wife he'll tell that to
the FBI oh yeah
yeah let's jump into the story for the
post-millennial
rich women of the view want illegal
immigrants in New York resettled
elsewhere uh what no no no no no no no
this is a sanctuary City okay but
frankly you know I think we need to find
and we've dealt with this before I I
lived in uh in Miami I was a migrant an
immigrant in Miami in the 80s you all
remember when we had the Marielle Boat
Lift 125
000 Cubans came in a matter of six
months it puts tremendous stress on on
on a city on a community on the social
services they need to be resettled
elsewhere
this is a massive country and it's only
going to get worse with global warming
and climate change
okay I'm gonna pause right there Joy
Behar and um I don't know the other
lady's name no you're a sanctuary City
you voted for it uh New York is a
sanctuary City we should keep sending
more in fact I I hereby call on all
border states to send as many people as
possible to New York City they
absolutely should well there are a lot
of places especially like New York and
these people will vote for stuff because
they're so isolated from it like they're
not there they're not on the border oh
yeah you know Texas New Mexico Arizona
they have to see it every day because
that is where the flood is coming yeah
and that they're they're over there two
and a half thousand miles away like oh
this is fine oh we should be a sanctuary
Stadium like that's really nice you
don't have to deal with it disgusting
and that's why they that's why they can
can have those opinions because it's not
real to them it's an abstraction that
they don't have to worry about that
doesn't touch them now that that's why
Eric Adams is all oh we're always going
to be a sanctuary City because the
number of actual illegal immigrants that
they were getting because of their
geographic location was totally
manageable
as soon as you change the situation and
start launching people in a New York
City all that of that bravado about
worst Sanctuary cities that stuff's out
the window because in reality these
policies that they swear up and down
that they want to have don't effing work
period just don't work like you have re
you have bumped into reality and when
your ideology bumps into reality friggin
reality wins every freaking time
you are on the border you live on the
border my house is probably as a crow
flies like maybe two and a half three
hours from the Mexican border two and a
half three hours do you spend this
you're running for the house uh
representatives for 23rd District uh
yeah TX uh cd23 what's the Border
situation like in your district oh it's
it's and it's atrocious like it's it's
so uh the Texas district 23 I I'd liken
it to like a dual sided wrench right
it's like the western side of San
Antonio uh to the Eastern side of El
Paso so it has more border Frontage in
that District than any District in the
country
and it's it's just insane you see a lot
of these border towns and whatnot are
dealing with this problem every day and
you have the the the class of Rich
liberal intellectuals that can postulate
about these things but they don't have
to see it they're isolated from it so
they they
they they get to have these you know
Fantastical opinions about oh this is
why the way we should be treating them
and oh I can't believe you do that but
they're not seeing the fact that and now
a statistically
uh important percentage of the U.S
population in the last five years the
increase in the U.S population has come
from illegal immigrants crossing the
southern border you know what the number
is I I heard the the term five million
or the the figure 5 million the other
day in the last uh I think since Biden
took office I'm not sure if that's
correct I imagine that so many of them
are undocumented yeah five million that
are document that are away people are
aware of so like is this is no real way
to know is this yeah what's the
sentiment of the people in the 23rd
District like oh from especially not
only just from common sense but from all
the polling that we're doing is like the
the immigration issue is the number one
issue in the district these people are
fed up with it and they're fed up with
the way that politicians are handling it
how would you protect the district what
would you do different like so I I like
a lot of like chip Roy stuff some of the
stuff he's put up which like Tony has
actively worked against Tony Gonzalez
the incumbent Republican I'm running
against uh because he's
it's basically just a trying to shut
down the Border entirely
which is what the guy is trying to do
that's what chip Roy yeah chip Roy's
actually I would say a really really
good Republican he's uh he runs uh the
district that uh Bernie Texas right down
the road for me uh that that District uh
he's he's got some really really good so
like he's a very firm border guy shut it
down like what would that first of all
what does it even look like is it just
flat people can just walk across a
sidewalk or is it a river depends
there's there's well there's there's a
river there that that's a lot of the the
viral footage that's gone you know
around the internet lately where they
had the the buoys with the the quote
unquote saw blades oh yeah oh yeah we
gotta remove those now yeah I think uh
there there's been a lot of moves by the
Biden Administration to actually
actively remove uh border barricades and
things were those put up by locals uh
they were put out by the state I believe
I believe and it's like they were
floating buoys with literal saw blades
between the buoys
yeah yeah I looked at it it's not like a
like a malicious looking saw blade it
looks like a piece of you know sheet
metal that has a jagged edge it was
cutting people and killing them or
something
that's why they have to remove it okay
so that's it when you say shutting down
what would a shutting down of the Border
look like because I feel like it's not
like what does that mean exactly well
there's a lot of border patrol folks
especially that are tasked with managing
that section of the border that aren't
given the equipment and anything that
they they need so that that they're
purposely being uh I guess suppressed in
that way there's a lot of frustration so
uh is that excuse me headline from New
York Daily News two bodies found stuck
in Rio Grande floating barrier along U.S
Mexico border according to Mexican
officials yeah yeah if you didn't know
saw blades were in there you could might
try and swim and climb over it but I
don't know if they're saw blades oh I
don't think the the saw blades were the
reason why they died it's what's
something that's also not really talked
about very often is that finding dead
migrants is just a thing that happens in
other taxes all the time like there's a
there's a ranch down the road in Uvalde
that we go to a lot uh that uh has had
issues with that were like there are
literally dead migrants will wash up and
they just find them and that's that's a
good uh two hours in from the border
I feel like historically it's been the
most when when countries have had to
deal with mass mass migration like
against their will that it's been the
most gruesome defensive measures have
been taken and they just don't document
it because like otherwise or you hear
about the Roman Empire getting
overthrown by the immigration and let me
be let me be really clear this is not
like U.S defensive border policy that's
killing them it's it's just the elements
if you've ever tried to walk anywhere in
Texas with limited Provisions for days
at a time that is a very very deadly
Venture if you're not careful walk a
mile like today outside here never mind
Texas is like over 100 for the entire
time I was there yeah whatever the the
entire last week I was just back in in
San Antonio it's like 107 degrees is
kind of the normal in the middle of the
day what would be an example of U.S
defensive measures
you know it's one of those things where
it's like you know you can call the wall
what you will but a lot of Democrats
said that the wall was just a massive
waste of money
so it's some of the lower estimates were
like single digit billion dollars like
eight billion dollars but we can give
hundreds of billions to Ukraine yeah
that's money that they need to send to
Pakistan to teach kids about gender
studies right right so it's like that
that's a that's a good you know that's a
good starting place and also giving the
the border patrol folks the the
equipment and the things that they need
to actually do their job like what what
equipment uh whether it's you know uh
just a the ability to staff the people
that they need like the people they need
to actually work the Border uh Vehicles
access to resources like the states are
willing to do that but the federal
government isn't
oh
federal government are they withholding
federal funds from the the process or
are they actually legally impeding State
Defense
I'm not sure if they've legally impeded
State Defense they're like doing a lot
like a lot of stuff like this I've seen
there was one example I think it was the
uh it was the the counter measure that
they put up in the water was they were
told to remove but there was another one
I think it was like in Arizona or New
Mexico that they were told to take the
potatoes yeah yeah the shipping
container thank you yeah they blocked
off waterways with shipping containers
nope just flat ground yep and they made
a makeshift walls and shipping
containers and they're like ah you can't
do that and they're like why and they're
like we don't know but you know oh my
God yeah so it's like a state trying to
protect their own border and the federal
government actively said like you know
and it's not a tax it's not a taxpayer
money thing because they if if that were
the case they would just leave it there
but they said no you actively have to
remove this now someone said it was on
Twitter that the reason that they're
allowing the federal government's
allowing such Mass migration is
immigration is because uh the birth
rates are down and they need new slave
labor the tongue-in-cheek slave though
they need a new citizenry and like
unless we're gonna have a bunch of kids
they're the writing's on the wall and
they need a larger population if they
were that philanthropic about it I think
they would openly say it
yeah like we need more people right
which is not the argument that they're
making they're not they're not that
transparent so there's there's obviously
something else at work what like a wall
what else I mean is there any how can
you prevent this this Mass illegal Mass
migration well on there well there's a
lot of a lot of things like I said like
giving excuse me giving uh like border
patrol the the tools that they need to
actually uh do their jobs a wall is a
good start but really I like a lot of
the things that I think that would help
or uh you know just the the removal of a
lot of the entitlements too
because it's like if you remove
entitlements
a lot of that desire to migrate goes
away like you've actually seen too and
it's it's a it's an actual uh observable
effect
the way that the U.S economy fluctuates
has effect on illegal immigration from
Mexico yeah which is a really
interesting stat you talk about that
that's one of the things that like
Libertarians like a lot like so there's
a lot of open borders Libertarians that
they're kind of like you know people
don't you know countries shouldn't exist
you you should just be able to move
freely where you want and stuff the only
kind of board is that there should be
are property uh borders for property
rights if you have if you have property
you can say people can come on to it but
you can't States shouldn't be able to do
that and stuff
and to me it's compelling in the idea
that like people should be free right
like that's genuinely that's what my gut
instinct is but you can't have an open
border and be giving away the type of
entitlements that we do here in the U.S
you know when you've got Social Security
unemployment I all kinds of all kinds of
uh social programs that are that are
available to people that come to the uh
that that come to the US or that are
that are citizens of the U.S if you get
rid of the entitlements then you can
have open borders because the situation
is if you want to come here and work
come work even just listen to the
conversation that they're having about
in New York and where they're getting a
lot of these migrants bust in the
conversations they're having is like how
do we logistically how do we feed these
people how do we clothe these people how
do we put them into homes how do we wash
their clothes like how do we do all
these things how do we teach their
children it's like these are all just
strains on the economic system I have an
idea thrown into you don't you don't
because they're here illegally and they
shouldn't be here send them home you
gotta go back I mean you can go home you
know huge deportation you you support
that now hold on it depends on what you
tie I I propose a program where when
people come to the Border
we ask them what country are you coming
from
and we asked them a few we have a
questionnaire about their country and
our country
and they're allowed to stay
because at the same time communist
leftists are lining up on the other side
of the Border
and we do a one-for-one swap with the
anti-communist Venezuelans and Cubans
for the Communist hipster brooklynites
and I think we can all agree that's a
good thing that's a that's like uh what
you think people do with like prisoners
of War they call it repopulation where
they would just take a huge section
if it's against their will otherwise
you're on the southern border and
there's a line of people and the guy
walks up it's like where you're from
like Venezuela and it's like okay and uh
your views on socialism it's really bad
I want to go to America it's like okay
and you sir uh you're where are you from
I'm from Brooklyn and you look communism
I do swap
you know you go to Venezuela you go to
Cuba you go to you go to Communism land
like you dreamed of so like it social
security goes to illegal immigrants at
the moment I don't I really don't know
what what kind of entitlements these
people are getting at the moment I don't
think it's Social Security but think
about what you can get without an ID
yeah and there's a lot
and so uh you can you can actually get
an ID without uh proper documentation
and then once you have an ID you can
apply for literally anything
people people don't understand that uh
our system of you know welfare
it's it's not like everything's
integrated perfectly and they know
exactly who everyone is all the time
it's not like this gigantic Mainframe
has your face your social your Facebook
profile and then when you apply they're
like it all makes sense now when you go
to one agency they're like probably
that's why a lot of people who are not
citizens get driver's licenses and they
get registered to vote there was an old
lady who voted not being a citizen
because they uh she got her license they
automatically registered registered her
she did not know she wasn't allowed to
do it or whatever it doesn't matter and
they were like that's a felony you're
going to prison you're not a citizen you
can't vote
but it's like that's how it works and
thank God there is no over overarching
you know entity that has all this
information because could you imagine
how scary the federal government would
be if they were competent it was just AI
being like you said 19 years ago the way
your eyes shifted when this was said
indicates that you are not trustworthy
um
yeah they I've heard that the Department
of Education is a total mess that the
the loan programs who owes what is just
a no one has any idea what's going on
people paperwork's lost and misplaced it
I don't know I've heard of Education
gives out loans uh in uh in conjunction
with like yeah I don't know anything
about that but I agree that the
Department of Education is a mess
they've been spending more money every
year since their Inception in 1979.
grade scores have been going down every
year since their Inception in 1979. the
idea that people couldn't be educated
before the Department of Education is
actually ridiculous all of the important
discoveries in the 21st century were
made pre-1970 or in the 20th century my
bad in pre-1979 like split the atom
design nuclear power plants blah blah
blah all this stuff happened before the
Department of Education we will be fine
without the freaking Department of
Education
people say that oh we're gonna have
people that don't understand
Newton wrote the principia he figured
out how gravity freaking works and the
math to describe it without the
Department of Education
I tend to lean on the side of you know
government no matter what it's doing is
the black thumb of Industry 100 nothing
will be better because the government
runs it it's like should we take care of
our veterans absolutely that's a
fantastic thing to do should we create a
government program to do it
that's that's where you get the VA and
that the absolute cluster that that is I
don't know anybody that says they they
think the VA is really really good no
there's there's people that kill
themselves in the VA regularly there's
people that kill themselves in the VA
parking lot
yeah no like literally I meant yeah like
in the lobby yeah that's that is a thing
that happens regularly and we don't talk
about it so like privatizing an aspect
of that you think could be a good
business opportunity uh not even a
business opportunity but like just like
it we I think at a certain point should
look at the obligations that we have to
our veterans and realize like okay is
there a private sector solution to this
that doesn't end up like private prisons
you know
interesting the the thing about
centralized power and authority is if it
works okay I guess it's working
decentralized might be better but when
it fails the entire system fails that's
the that's why that's why even if you
have a government program that works
marginally or or works even also say say
well right even if you have a government
program that works well you had to risk
the government program not working being
instituted never going away because
government programs don't go away look
at the Patriot Act look at all the stuff
that we still have that everybody talks
about how much they hate what was that
Mill I think it was Milton Friedman
there's nothing more permanent than a
temporary government yeah yeah
absolutely but why don't we attach
Sunset Clauses to all of the all new
bills I love this I love love love this
but that asking them to attach Sunset
Clauses is like asking them to vote for
themselves to get a pay cut right
oops I like Sunset Clauses that makes a
lot of sense yeah yeah no matter what
the law is because it's a good law
everyone will be like okay yeah fine
yeah keep and a lot of programs would
still maintain their funding like uh all
in favor of funding the you know
Department of Education bang no question
no questions asked you know all a favor
not funny but reinstating the the like a
lot of these programs would just stay
some of them people would be like I have
no idea what that program is like
there's laws that shouldn't be on the
books that are on the books and they
just be like we we vote on that well
they never repeal laws they just stop
enforcing them which is a terrible idea
because that means the government still
has that power and then they can go
ahead and say oh well he did this thing
and you know what there's this weird uh
obscure law from 150 years ago and we
can blah blah blah and we can charge him
with this they were doing that I forget
the name of the ACT but they were doing
that with with Trump what was it the uh
Logan the Logan yeah you know you know
what I really want to do
if I if if I was a cop in Florida I
would I would drive I would look up in
my jurisdiction skydiving
I would ask them like where do you
typically land like when you guys are
coming down
and then as soon as the women land with
their parachutes I would arrest them on
the spot on Sundays it is illegal for
you to skydive on Sunday and they'd be
like what and I feel like here's the law
jail that's your fault you go to
jail
you go to Boston they have laws it works
like you can't put a pie in your window
so on a Tuesday or something like that
it's like Sunday and the reason was back
when when everything was really small
putting a pie in the window cell could
attract animals and it was like a church
Gathering where no one was around so
then a bear would wander in the town so
they're like you guys got to stop
putting pies on your windowsills to cool
and so you show up look around for
someone who's got a pipe near because
I'm thinking I was actually putting it
on but I looked at that window and if I
see a pie anywhere near that I'm like
ma'am you're under arrest this is uh it
looks like the law you were referencing
in Florida was struck down what no my
law is Florida has lawlessness in which
unmarried women are not allowed to go
parachuting on Sundays then it says not
anymore and it's doubtful there ever was
this is from Skeptics I'm very curious
why it was specifically unmarried when
Florida oh dude dude
it's illegal to cohabitate unless you're
married
so
like you know what man we need reform in
this country laws need to go away
yeah if you're going to enforce these
laws against Trump I want to see some
cop be like uh excuse me sir I couldn't
up but notice that woman with you is
going into the same building do you both
live here we do you're under arrest
you're not married you're under arrest
imagine how much harder it is to be an
attorney nowadays than it was in 1874.
just how many more laws just by volume
okay yeah it's a it was a fine anyway
was it because they didn't want to show
their underwear or something there's
only single women no parachute it was it
was a petty offense so it's just you get
a ticket for it
which is so weird I love these crazy I
just love that this is after the plane
but before modern common sense
oh was it what parachuting specifically
yeah I don't know when the law was
originated well I just assume it had to
be after the airplane right because you
can't jump out right playing with a
parachute and I do think that base
jumping came after uh planes because
they had to invent the parachute yo this
one really really irks me it's illegal
in Maryland to sell cars on Sunday no a
lot of states have that law and so is
that still enforced yes no they're all
shut down on Sundays yup so when we were
when we were we needed to guess like a
vehicle for for you know guests uh
pickup and stuff
when can I go I do a Morning Show Nitro
I can't go during the during the week
just Saturday ah but everyone closes
early on Saturday so it's like the only
day I could go to buy a car is Saturday
and then on Sunday it's like they're all
closed I think it's true in Virginia as
well where's that law come from
uh Church
oh
yep
blue laws that's what they're called
blue laws
yep they had blue laws in Massachusetts
for a long time stuff like you couldn't
be uh couldn't have stores open on
Sundays and stuff when I was growing up
but by the time I was a teenager like
they were all gone uh they actually I
think they actually did repeal them but
I'm not 100 sure wow blue laws illegal
restriction designated for Sunday
activity yep
Oklahoma no you can't make faces at a
dog we had a listico from BuzzFeed
illegal to eat a frog if it died during
a frog jumping competition
illegal to sing in your swimsuit oh man
this is it Florida you go to Miami Beach
you put on Bohemian Rhapsody and then as
soon as the people inevitably start
singing you go man you're under arrest
you are under arrest
you know two reviews and see their abs
you can't have a donkey sleeping in your
bathtub after 7 PM no in Arizona bro if
I want my donkey my bathtub make no one
tell me otherwise look at this one
Kansas it's illegal to serve ice cream
with cherry pot on Cherry Pie I remember
this one this one's like a very famous
example of a weird law
and I don't know what the reason was
they don't know how I got in the books
it's against the law to eat an orange
while taking a bath
some of these just had to be
legislatures just screwing with people
right at a fill of laws
no they're like wouldn't this be funny
won't people talk about this a hundred
years from now yeah
I don't understand the no orange in a
bath I don't I mean I know Florida is
known for oranges what it's illegal to
Eat Fried Chicken by any other means
than your hands what see with a fork you
can't do it a fork wow
that's funny here we go in Louisiana a
woman can't drive a car without her
husband waving a flag in front of it
that's why I've never gotten a wreck
also Virginia as well
only on Main Street though
the husband has to walk in front of her
waving a red flag wow so single women
can't drive period Citizen's dumbass
doesn't mean it's illegal to bite your
landlord dude it's illegal everywhere to
bite anyone yeah
that's not that's assault yeah that's a
salt what is this law you can't throw
knives at men wearing striped suits you
can't throw knives at anyone come on
even if they but maybe it's if they it's
if they're like it's okay this time you
know no it's still not just so you know
once upon a time in Hollywood things
like if I kill someone on accident you
know these hands are deadly weapons
Stripes cause an optical illusion which
messes with my anybody kills anyone on
accident it's manslaughter you can't eat
hamburgers on Sunday in Minnesota
gotta change wow what a weird world
can't eat cottage cheese on Sunday in
Florida
don't tie a crocodile to a to an
alligator crocodile or an alligator to a
fire hydrant
well okay then I can see that being a
fire hazard like you can't eat ice cream
after 6 PM in New Jersey repurchase you
can't purchase purchase it yeah but you
can eat it
well there you go welcome to America I
have no idea how any of that is real
it's illegal to push a moose out of a
moving airplane you know that happened
quite a bit in Alaska if they had to
make it illegal how do you get a moose
onto an airplane oh you just walk them
on the back cargo there's uh so you guys
know exactly cargo planes they're
pushing them out of that's that's cool
what's that uh what's that strip in um
Montana or is it Wyoming the strip of
death or whatever the zone of death
where there's no uh there's no legal
peers so you can't be criminally charged
I don't know oh I've heard I've heard of
Yellowstone yeah it's and Yellowstone
the show they use it as a prop Montana
260 square miles no no that's the park
is 260 square miles yeah there's a strip
of land where no one lives and so the
Constitution requires a journey of your
peers but there's no one in this
jurisdiction so they can't actually
convene it and it's the silliest thing
that people would argue technically you
could kill someone there and you can't
go to jail because there's no jury and
it's like dude if you go on a boat and
go out to international waters and then
kill someone you will be charged with
murder it doesn't matter where you are
you can't just go and commit crimes be
like ah but I was in a special place the
zone of death is a 50 square mile area
in the Idaho section of Yellowstone
National Park in which as a result of a
reported loophole in the Constitution of
the United States a person could
theoretically avoid conviction for any
major crime up to and including murder
I bet they'll still through yeah there
has to be an incident of somebody trying
that yeah what does Wikipedia say no
there was a guy who killed like a bull
moose or something and then when they
tried to criminally prosecute criminally
charge him for it he said oh yeah I will
challenge you on constitutional grounds
and then they came back and said if you
do that we'll give you the maximum if
you plead guilty you'll get a slap on
the rest so he plea he pleaded guilty oh
geez yeah
which means they were not ready for that
Court fight
he'd probably win
uh
but I I think at this point the way
things are going in this country you
can't expect the courts to actually
operate yeah when we were when we were
dealing with a lawsuit the first
question the lawyer we talked to ask is
which state are you filing in
because if you file in California you
lose if you follow file in West Virginia
you win depending on what you're asking
if you're filing if you are a leftist
media publication in California and you
file a lawsuit against a Conservative
Republican whatever you win instantly if
you are a conservative and California
file a lawsuit against a liberal you
lose instantly West Virginia more likely
for the conservative one for obvious
reasons yeah and I'm just like you know
when I hear things like that from my
lawyer I just don't think this country
is in a healthy place
but that's the reality it's like the
least unhealthy country but that doesn't
mean that's true right we're we're we
actually do really really well in a lot
of ways but it's falling apart
what's that quote it's like it's the
democracy is the worst system except for
all the others yeah yeah Winston
Churchill oh we're not democracy you
know it's a constitutional republic and
it's actually the best he was British so
you know we hear that thunder thunder
yeah sounds like it how's the uh
campaign been so far really positive so
far it's been really nice uh we're
accomplishing our goal of uh threatening
the seat of a rhino so that's that's
always a pleasure what are your um like
tactics to campaign I mean obviously TV
shows well so we're doing really uh it's
it's been uh a lot of just Grassroots
efforts so we don't have a lot of the
big the we don't have any any packs any
super Pacs anything crazy like that
we've just been doing entirely
Grassroots and and really it's it's kind
of unconventional because this is the
first time I think it's ever uh
anybody's ever utilized social media to
the degree that we have for something
like this so a lot of it is uh Twitter
meme Warfare Instagram meme Warfare
getting it kind of Tony Gonzalez is one
of those politicians not a lot of people
know about you know there's a lot of of
uh P there's a lot of politicians
whether it's AOC or Dan Crenshaw people
that are very polarizing figures but
that's only because people talk about
them there's a lot of people with worse
voting records people don't know about
like Tony because they completely slide
under the radar so bringing him into the
public light and showing bad votes like
him but voting for for Biden's
post-evalde gun control you know things
like that people don't know about it
what was his that vote the post-opality
gun control what was that uh it was uh
bill it was like the safer communities
act which voted to fund I think it was a
lot of mental health stuff and a lot of
States uh red flag laws and a bunch of
other things that that came down after
the Uvalde school shooting that he not
only voted for but said he would uh he
didn't regret voting for it and he would
vote for it twice twice again on Sunday
like a red flag laws meaning if someone
has some sort of psychiatric issue they
would come and threaten to take their
weapons or something well red flag laws
are kind of their own uh interesting
issue because it dependencity yeah it
varies state to state but realistically
it's a way that people can you know
whether it's your neighbor who doesn't
like that your tree is too far over into
his backyard or it's your you know
ex-wife who has a an ax to grind people
can just call and say like hey I think
he might be doing something you should
go take his guns because I don't feel
safe and then the police will show up
and do that has it happened yes and
there are incidents of people dying in
shootouts because of it and I think one
of them was in Maryland if I'm not
mistaken I might be I might be wrong on
that but I think it happened recently uh
in the last couple years so this dude in
Texas that you're running against that
voted for that stuff did it actually go
through yes I believe it did crazy
so can you repeal that
uh if it's voted on you
we have a we had a story
Elon suing uh no California we'll just
pull this one up I mean we're kind of
we're pushing into the Super Chat stuff
but this is uh from The New York Times
and it's it's being it was updated
literally like seven minutes ago New
York Times says appeals court rules
White House overstepped First Amendment
on social media offensive a fifth
circuit panel partly upheld restrictions
on the Biden administration's
Communications with online platforms
about their content basically they said
that uh
the Biden Administration violated the
Constitution by telling social media
companies to remove covid misinformation
and uh hello that's a good thing that's
a huge Victory big victory right now the
uh Elon Musk is uh acts as suing
California under this law and uh uh not
this one but under a law that basically
would allow censorship and collusion and
stuff so you know how you guys doing I'm
doing pretty I love debating this stuff
talking about covet like that's one of
the biggest sadnesses of the 2021 is
like I wanted to talk about it I wanted
to find out what was better what was
right what was wrong what was like and
it's I understand the fear of like you
don't want to go on TV until 100 million
people something that could get them
killed like I get that aspect of it but
debating It And discussing it and
questioning it
and I also understand like terrifying
Health emergencies thing oh what if
people are dying actually bleeding out
you know from flesh eating bacteria you
don't want to tell them you know don't
worry about it but the terrifying nature
though of having our Silicon Valley
overlords say that they are the Arbiters
of Truth and that discourse isn't
allowed if they don't agree with it
that's that's its own separate issue
yeah and it should be I think that the
federal government has a duty to to
prevent that from happening personally
sorry Phil no no the the externalities
are always the point or are always the
problem like so the things that the
government wants to do sometimes they're
bad sometimes they don't look bad
sometimes they actually aren't a bad
plan but that doesn't mean that they can
plan for all the externalities and it's
all of the things that happen
consequently because of a gun because of
a law that gets passed that tend to
cause problems because people aren't
prepared for them I mean it's like if
you pass laws that don't solve the
problem then you've got new laws you've
got enforcement you've got people losing
their their rights and stuff like that
and you still have the problem
so and once a law is passed again we
talked about it earlier once the laws
passed it never gets repealed because of
the incentive in government you're never
going to have a politician say you know
what that law is bad the law that I
passed that law is bad and it's not
working we need to repeal it because my
constituents are suffering no they're
going to say no we need to do this and
do more and blah blah blah blah it's
never oh this isn't working well stop
it's oh it isn't working throw more
government at it what's easier too is to
retcon it which is what that is an
annoying Trend that I've realized where
they wreck on it where they say no no we
never forced anybody to get the vax we
never forced anybody to do that it was
it was something you know you weren't
legally required to it's just that if
you worked for the government in any
capacity whether you were uh EMS uh uh a
cop any sort of position like that we
would just you know it was policy to
fire you but you weren't forced to you
had the choice you could just you know
quit your job you know two years before
you you retire like it just that that
retconning of yeah no that's called
forcing people to do it yeah
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends and become a member over at
timcast.com by clicking join us at the
website to support our work directly and
as a member uh your memberships are used
to fund a whole array of of kooky
cultural Endeavors I think the crazy
thing we're trying to do right now is
create an anti-time Square we're gonna
open a cast brew coffee shop a cousin
T's Diner a Papa Jack Papa Jack
pastobics Pizza Shack and uh hopefully
we can get a my pillow brick and mortar
shop
and then create this like block long
downtown area in West Virginia of all of
these businesses that that is I got my
eyesight on that I think we can do it
all it takes is we go one step at a time
so I'm excited for that but that's
that's basically what we do when you
become a member that's what we're
focused on all right we're gonna read
your super chance I'm gonna start with
this one it's uh from a little later on
but I want to read it
uh the r heretic with his grossly
incorrect assessment said watching Tim
eat his words on the Second Amendment
after his naive counter to yesterday's
guest from Venezuela about America's
expanding gun rights in real time is
worth 20 even if he doesn't read this
Super Chat as usual except I was still
100 correct in everything I said so uh
Gus basically said we're losing our gun
rights and that's actually not true
yeah we expansion of constitutional
carry and a bunch of stuff on the state
level like oh you do it really well half
the country is now constitutional carry
there's no question the only reason the
new the New Mexico Governor can make
this degree is because New Mexico went
from no issue to Shell issue and now
that it's a shell issue State they have
to allow people to get guns and now
they're trying to go back to how it was
like in the 90s and it's more than half
I think now it's like uh what like 27
States uh at least 26. yeah there's 26
listed but maybe because one's pending
yeah but there's more than half the
country where you don't need a permit
and see your point is right
um and the the actual situation isn't
that gun rights are Contracting like he
said it's that the government is
overstepping its legal boundaries the
federal yeah right isn't isn't allowed
but right
gun rights has been have been expanding
tremendously DC versus Heller was huge
and now we have constitutional carry
across the board half the country and
what happened in New Mexico today was
panicked desperation from a despot who's
issuing a decree that will get struck
down by the Supreme Court in two seconds
and here's the best part what it does it
will set precedent that executive orders
can cannot infringe upon constitutional
rights it'll probably be a bit more
narrow than that and they'll say
protecting the guns but hopefully it's a
bit more Broad and you can see even in
specific instances like state
constitutions for example where they're
like well except for concealed carry you
know different things like that where
there's even more careful verbiage when
those Clauses were added years ago than
there is now people are now opening up
to things like uh Nationwide reciprocity
and stuff like that which is not a
conversation that would have happened in
the 90s all right we got RJ McDougall
says did I win yes sir you were the
first Super chatter you beat I'm not
your buddy guy who said
they only take away your guns because
what they're about to do next would make
you want to use them
that's what worries me
all right
Anthony Brownlee says OMG it's the AK
God I hope you win in Texas and bring
down some of those damn gun restrictions
to it for life
what what inspires you to call your uh
the AK guy your Twitter channel the
ak-50 that he has yet to deliver the
chat is going nuts by the way I've seen
so many people complaining about the
fact of that there's not been a
legitimate suppliers blame bad American
manufacturing is what it is no we've got
a big update coming on that soon we got
we actually just got our new receiver in
yesterday and I was totally functional
what we say we who is we me and my team
so I've got a team of of Miss Krantz
that are helping me out with a lot of
stuff in the shop you know whether it's
design stuff or or manufacturing for
your company what company uh the AK guy
Inc so that that's that's the name of
the company now but it used to be my
YouTube handle back in the day when I
was you know I was the the weird AK guy
of the group because I always like the
AK platform I always had a fascination
with it you guys manufacture weapons in
general just Weaponry uh yes um more
specifically the AK platform but we do a
lot of like you know uh especially stuff
for the YouTube channel to show off uh
like World War II machine guns uh
different just Firearms throughout
history because I'm fascinated at the
solution of arms you know all the way
back from the 1800s flintlocks all the
way to you know the first machine gun
the first submachine gun uh you know
just the evolution of firearms has
always been intriguing to me have you
seen these guns that are being built
with graphene the new ones uh in what uh
which they just use them in the body I
just saw a 22 that was being created I
should have logged it but they're
lightweight you see that guy over there
the big one not the little one yeah
that's an actual uh Union Civil War
rifled musket do you know where it was
made uh no it's probably on there I
think it might be Springfield okay yeah
I was just curious because Harper's
Ferry is pretty close so yeah like you
know I don't think they made them here
did they I think they did oh well then
it may be I got that antique store they
were uh so these are particularly common
there were 10 000 of them that were made
and never used they were just left in an
Armory uh more importantly the union
stopped uh started using breach loading
uh rifles uh uh it's one of the one of
the reasons the South lost Gettysburg
was that uh Confederates were marching
into getting
with muzzle loaded rifled muskets and
the union had paper cartridge breach
loading right Burnside carbines I think
is that what they're called I think so
is that correct brake action breach load
yep you pull the trigger guard down it
pops open the the chamber pops open you
throw it in and I think you guys have a
Burnside carbine yeah yeah those things
are right I was that in that cheap store
yeah they had uh one of the early I
think was an early Winchester where you
load in the in the stock yeah yeah crazy
like how does it and then uh I do love
the side load you know so I've got I've
got a Winchester over there and it's
it's it's it's awful I'm sorry it just
it's super cool it looks cool but trying
to load a 30 30 and the and the and the
mag tube just jams every single time and
then I've when I when I deal with this
I'm like I must be doing something wrong
so I ask everybody like no it sucks
mine's a Burnside Edge the Burnside
carbine is uh was the it was invented by
Ambrose Burnside the dude who wears
sideburns come from get a picture of
this guy it was the most productive
active thing uh Burnside ever did for
the north because he was a terrible
General he was a general and an inventor
like we need more military men that are
inventors that's what made this country
so great in the beginning just like uh
sir here and Maxim uh the guy who
invented the Maxim gun like is it
maximum machine gun that that changed
Warfare that changed the world forever
that movie crap he was an inventor he
invented a bunch of bunch of stuff he
had the early uh concepts for the
helicopter he actually invented the
first real inhaler
and that was people basically called him
a bit of a dork for it and he's like
look I invented something for the
betterment of mankind watch me create a
death machine and that's well uh what
people will know me for
and 100 years later it's a little crazy
the Burnside carbine was 38.50 in 1861.
so what what is that by U.S like current
dollars I'm not sure but now I looked it
up when I when I got it from my uh dad
um and at the time it was a couple
thousand dollars for this for mine and
mine in my perfect condition uh
apparently
today's prices are 34 times as high
so 34 Times Higher that might be than
1861. I don't know if that's true or not
it would be 1 399. is that what you said
yeah dude Ambrose Burnside the the
firing range a 200 yard shot for a for
something like that is legit for Bare
iron sights yeah that's
pretty decent yeah
they had some real like decent
long-range stuff back in the day like
Kentucky rifles and stuff like that the
real like Craftsman made guns not
necessarily the mass production sure but
the Craftsman stuff you could get some
surprising distance out of that why
would they have that made him so good uh
attention to detail like especially when
you're talking about early cutting of
rifling and things like concentricity
mattered a lot like and that's that
early Machining this is before
electricity so like if you ever go down
to like Harpers Ferry and see how they
made some of this stuff it's really cool
how they basically have it attached to a
water mill
and that they have a belt system going
through the ceiling and everything
that's turning their lathes where they
were cutting barrels and stuff it's
really neat the the kind of arcade yeah
I went on that tour is really cool oh
did you it's really yeah yeah all right
raybert G Stan Junior says Tim I
understand how you maintained your
composure this morning when Brianna
invited you to promote voting as if you
don't do it almost every day that's
literally the first thing I said to Tim
when he came or when I came in today I
was like dude how did you not kill
yourself but my view is uh
I I I thought it was a good conversation
I operate under the assumption uh
typically that the people who are coming
here from the left and liberals don't
know a lot of new stuff and that is not
to I'm not trying to insult them they
get insulted when I say that but I'm
like I'm not trying to insult you you
told me you didn't read the news story
so I know
there is a one-to-one chance
okay it's unfair but like a 95 chance we
bring in someone who's liberal and ask
them about Victor shock and bursma
cutter turkey pipeline Etc other than
say I don't know what that is and I'm
like okay
then how can you have an opinion on the
impeachment of trump if you don't know
what happened in Ukraine with Victor
shoken and all this stuff and then the
response is well like you know I read
enough about it my attitude is like by
all means come on the show and say
exactly that it's not for me I don't
need to hear it everyone watching hears
it and they take a clip of you saying
I did not read that story I don't know
and that's all I need to hear and then
when next time you make an argument we
just attach that clip to it and we say
these are people who take strong
political positions without researching
those stories I was asked by Brent about
Casey Anthony said I have no idea I did
not I don't know anything about that
story I have no opinion more than just
not researching what will happen is
imagine if you're on the surface and
there's a garden and you're like where
are the roots for all these plants I
must get to the bottom of this and dig
down and you find the roots and you're
like I found it I know the answer is now
I'm satisfied Trump impeachment I get it
but then if you really dig deeper which
most people won't because they feel like
they already found the roots you go
deeper it opens up into a cave Network
where the roots continue to go deeper
and Trump's down there and most people
don't even know that game network exists
because they're already satisfied with
this this shitty Garden thing like
metaphor that I created like they've
already feel like they got the answer
every the mass media already fed them a
little bit so they they don't look
deeper I'm not saying that every single
do every single liberal I've talked to
about the Trump impeachment has outright
said they did not know Joe Biden engaged
in a quid pro quo and then another
component of it and and I'm not trying
to drag Brianna I thought the
conversation was really good it was
three and a half hours went very long uh
when I'm when when we talk about uh
Hunter Biden Hunter Biden according
Devon Archer testifies that Hunter was
called that Hunter calls DC and says the
prosecutor is a problem and we need help
Biden then flies out a few days later
and engages in an illegal quid pro quo
it's a fact and then brags about it and
then brags about it to CFR and there's
no legitimate response other than
if you guys have seen that interview
where the journalist has asked about
Hunter Biden saying my dad takes my
salary and he goes I don't know and he's
like you're saying there's no evidence
of corruption
and we have proof Hunter said my dad is
taking my money and he goes I don't know
it wasn't involved in his business so
this is what happens he asked about the
weather they'll either say I did not
read the story and then when you bring
it up they'll go I don't know
that's like well okay that's I I get it
I do not expect a Democrat to come in
here and go holy crap he did that now
that I didn't know I expect them to
dismiss it and I expect that clip to be
made and shared online to prove my point
and that's all I can there's no reason
for me to get mad I just say okay thank
you for explaining you don't care that
Joe Biden did this you don't think it's
a problem you're allowed to think those
things I am not mad at you for for
thinking Joe Biden should be allowed to
engage in a quid pro quo in fact when I
asked Brianna does Donald Trump have the
authority to threaten to withhold
congressionally approved loan guarantees
to a foreign president in exchange for a
political favor and Brenna would not
answer why
anyone who knows what actually happened
knows that's what Joe Biden did and so
the political answer and the smart way
to respond is to not answer that
question
because you get trapped because anyone
would say of course Trump can't do that
I got you Joe Biden did it unfortunately
Trump did the same thing and they said
Trump's not allowed to do that and I'm
like okay but he was that's what Joe
Biden did no no Joe Biden was allowed to
do it okay dude whatever I'm not mad
about it I know these people don't
actually know or care I just need to
prove it to other people I need to be
able to give that clip to my liberal
Aunt whoever I don't actually don't have
one but figuratively and be like there's
the clip to watch
and they go wait what and I'm like if
you choose to be on the side of I don't
care what's true I care if my tribe wins
tell me now
but to anyone who's not interested I can
show you this clip and you'll go
oh wow I didn't realize Joe Biden did
that okay well there you go he did have
a nice day
anyway let's read more
a lot of people saying let's go Brandon
we got to sa federally saying let's go
Brandon a lot of people are saying
where's my ak-50
yeah so that's a project we've been
working on for a while the uh it's
basically just a 50 BMG AK can you do a
a a a nine millimeter macro of carbine
yeah yeah that's pretty easy because
they uh
it's just it's just what is it like a is
it 18 9x18 I think or is that yeah nine
but nine by eighteen yeah it's like the
the Russian like it's almost like a
mixture between nine millimeter Luger
and 380 380 yeah yeah so I also I love
the macrov handgun too like it's just
which one though like the Makarov like
the Russian I have a I think it's called
like a p64 or something I think that was
Polish Polish that's right and it sucks
everyone hates it nobody wants to use it
it's ergonomic so it's only right-handed
and it bites and so I I had I had gloves
on in the winter yeah at the range
and it still bites your hand and I was
really excited to have this Polish
Soviet weapon and it's just not fun and
I was like does anybody else want to try
and like we're good we're good because
we have like a Beretta and we've you
know nobody the p64 they inexplicably if
I'm thinking about the right thing but
I'm thinking about it correctly I think
they inexplicably uh shrunk it a bit so
it's not as big as a regular yeah Jim
mcarov's not exactly big yeah it's a
eight plus one single second hand gun so
what happened was uh something happened
with ammo prices a few years ago I think
everybody remembers and you know hang
out with Luke and Luke's like you should
probably pick up some nine mil while you
can and so I'm like sitting on my couch
my eyes are half closed and I went to I
think it was ammo.com and I'm just
scrolling through and I'm like nine
millimeter by and I went just like
jamming the plus button and then I hit
order and then when it shows up Luke
walks into the box and he's like oh cool
the ammo's here and then he opens it and
he's like
this is Russian and I was like and he
opens the box he goes bro these aren't
nine millimeters and I was like what it
says nine millimeter and it's got all
Russian writing on it yeah so we ended
up with a very large quantity of Makarov
nine millimeter and then I was like
great success great success but uh the
company they're awesome I think it was
ammo.com they emailed me being like we
realized you ordered a large quantity of
Makarov rounds and may have made a
mistake if you're if you're if if that
was we will gladly ship out you know
nine millimeter Luger and I was like no
no no no I'm keeping this and I'm gonna
go find a Makarov a weapon and then a
local gun shop had uh uh the p64 yeah
and I was really excited to be like oh
cool Soviet and it just hurts and nobody
wants to use it you could definitely
re-barrel like a like a pp19 essentially
of the Chas uh which is like the AK nine
millimeter Carbine that they've got yeah
you could easily just well not easily
would take a good bit of work but you
could make up a custom uh nine
millimeter macrob barrel for that they
run them in nine by 18 in Russia but I
was talking to uh
uh gun shop if they're able to do that
and everybody says yes but we just never
did because we don't really care that
much but it would be cool to have like a
you know nine millimeter rifle of some
sort I think the Bison one the one with
the helical magazine on the bottom uh
that one is 9x18 or at least they had
one in nine by eighteen what's what's
that ridiculous 22 that's got the the
magazine goes on top yeah I got one of
those Calico yes yeah I got one of those
two they're so weird it's like the
Spaceballs guns right like stick out of
the top no no it's flat but it's got a
how many as a whole is a lot it's 100
yeah
because it's like a spiral staircase of
ammunition yeah all the way through the
gun yeah like it's it's like the P90
does the what's the horizontal magazine
yeah it's a similar thing where it's on
top but they're just sideways
to the shooter and then they've got like
a a rotary table that you know flips it
to the right orientation before it loads
in the chamber there's some cool old
stuff you can buy man I love uh Luke
wanted me to buy a nine millimeter crank
Gatling Cannon oh yeah yeah I was like
look come on and he was like come on you
got to get it and it's like I've got a
real one of those in the 45 Long pole
how is it I haven't shot it yet but
we're we want to do a Last Samurai video
with it nice oh oh they use it they
actually introduce machine gunning and
is that the plot of the movie is that's
like the dawn of the guns essentially
yeah it's it's if you haven't seen the
movie it's a fantastic film Tom Cruise
yeah for everybody that thinks the
machine guns are a recent invention
watch that one oh yeah I mean even uh
what like 1300s they had the
multi-barrel so it was like like a dozen
or two dozen barrels and they're all
muzzle loaded but then they would like
pull something and go
that's crazy I was looking at the
company's called Taurus USA that makes
this graphene gun it's called the gx4
graphene and and apparently it's
lightweight it's Taurus
like this must be emerging technology
and then I heard Taurus like oh this is
going to be 300 bucks and it's
disposable right is it are they known
for producing shoddy shoddy work I don't
want to rap on anybody they're not great
um I'm fascinated with graphene being
implemented in modern Weaponry because
it's so lightweight and durable yeah
all right you could probably make a cool
frame for like a Glock out of it let's
uh read some more Russian clear says 2A
is winning Tim pool you got to stop
saying this and resting on your laurels
until I as a regular citizen can dual
wield a full auto saw and a high point
with a switch then 2A hasn't won
anything
listen my friends graphene saw babe that
was an excellent tweet uh 2A is winning
it doesn't mean it's one right so
winning is repealing the NFA uh yeah
among other things but that's like that
that's a huge win
let's say that there is a a Big Field
let's say you're playing football
and you are pressed all the way back up
against the uh uh The End Zone and then
you actually start advancing forward
you are you are winning but you haven't
won or how about this let's say you're
playing baseball the other team
has like three runs and then uh you
score two in one run you have started
winning you have not won yet let's say
they have seven you know it's like the
sixth inning and they have seven runs
and you have eight you are winning they
still can can pull ahead that's why I
say well two-way stuff you can't stop we
have made tremendous gains massive gains
hit a few grand slams but there is still
an effort by democrats to ban
a standard issue standard capacity
weapons
claiming that 10 is too many when 10 is
is minimal it's it's it's it's it's it's
laughable everybody knows you're all gun
people you get it I'm just saying you've
got to recognize when you're winning
you need the morale boost you need the
charge you know we're we're getting this
but you have to make sure people don't
rest on their Laurels which is exactly
what I said yesterday we may be winning
with constitutional carry but we need to
get rid of the ATF in the NFA yep
in fact I'll be honest
the idea of an Alcohol Tobacco and
Firearms an explosive Division I have no
problem with as a surface level idea
that there is someone in charge of you
know overseeing this for some reason
what we don't need is a law enforcement
agency that questions whether or not
people have a right to keep in terms so
no
how about just the TFE
tobacco firearms and explore no no no no
the ate alko tobacco explosives Firearms
nuts still confusing me why alcohol and
Firearms are anywhere I mean I guess
drunk they're the fun police dude yeah
sons of no no no no I don't
drink drinking's bad but Firearms
constitutionally protected so I'll say
this
until
the Constitution is amended American
citizens have a right to keep and bear
nuclear and biological weapons
anti-matter weapons railguns you name it
and anything else is an infringement was
this one we're coming back to nuclear
weapons now
so you don't get to arbitrarily decide
that arms in the Constitution only
applies to what they had back then
it's in the greater context of what was
allowed uh private corporations build
nukes like where do people think nukes
come from so yes it's not it's not a uh
controversial for me to say private
individuals have the right to keep and
bear nuclear weapons in fact they quite
literally do right now there actually is
on the ATF e-form site when you where
you go as like an FFL to uh register
like hey like I'm building a machine gun
I'm you know building a suppressor I'm
doing whatever there is a slot on that
website to uh complete the form as I am
building a nuclear weapon well yeah
these these big weapons manufacturers
have to do it yeah and my my big thing
my big take on that was always like it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if it's
legal
the the thing that is stopping people
from
making nuclear weapons is not because
there is a law right yeah if there is
good luck if there is somebody like
let's say Elon Musk who had the billions
of dollars and let's say I don't know
thousands of Rocket Engineers to make
icbms and you know whatever he wants to
do
strangely starts buying a bunch of
plutonium and uranium and right oh well
people are going to start sweating real
hard because it's like the only thing
stopping him is not the law it's just he
hasn't decided to do it yet it's not
worth the legal headache what if Eli was
just like I'm gonna Duke Mars
nuke the poles yeah he had mentioned
that that might be a way to start to see
what did the Polish do to you oh oh got
it I love the polls but nuke the polls
of Mars uh it might super heat the the
Megan kick the magnetic field
yeah
it checks out
okay let's read some more comments here
what do we got Brahman says Congressman
Herrera you'll win as a letter carrier
I've had to deal with mountain lions Etc
and city of carriers deal with being
robbed and shot please keep in your mind
when you go to DC that postal workers
want to be armed when you go to DC I
like that kind of confidence there I
just hate the idea of having to go to DC
for anything yeah what you just spent 28
days a month in DC everyone's trying to
there's probably like 17 or 20 super
chats telling me that you have to say
the word trunion
I know this inside joke it says I don't
know what it means but like after like
the the 20th Super Chat I'm like okay
I'll just ask yeah it's the the
the the t word is the the rear t word on
on an AK and it's it's a running joke
with me and uh an angry cops he he likes
the way that I say trunnion
you guys go there you go cylindrical
protrusion angry as a mounting or
pivoting Point that's the definition
let's grab another Super Chat
oh where are we at where are we at it's
getting late
uh
people are mad at Ian uh no I doubt it
the mclum code says Ian I'm a Christian
and yes love does cover a multitude of
sins but not all of them for the rest
forgiveness follows repentance there is
no repentance from the left just Warfare
oh this is a black pill
but I think it's it's the general ideas
Republicans are not indicting Democrats
at all
Democrats are indicting tons of
Republicans and lawyers and media
personalities and the Republicans are
like guys please chill out before this
gets bad and they're like nah
and then you're like we should pardon
the Democrats I see humans targeting
humans right now and it's concerning I'm
looking for a way out so how about this
would you agree that
the people engaging in the hostilities
should stop doing it
you mean like the political yeah it's
like yeah absolutely I do not like using
the force of law to go after political
opponents I don't think that fear is the
way forward I don't think they're trying
to make Donald Trump disappear is going
to make the Trump movement disappear you
got to work together that's the whole
point of being an American
well there you go a lot of people are
also saying I think the entire thing was
that it's unilateral the the youth the
weaponization of the federal government
tends to be unilateral which like I'm
not saying the Republicans never do it
I'm just saying that the ideals that a
lot of Republicans and libertarian
leaning people hold prevents them in
their own moral compass from using the
weapons of government against their
opponents which is where they lose you
know sorry the ak-50 is that meant to be
full auto
so we have uh so it's a shoulder-fired
it's almost like a bearing I was serious
it's like a shoulder-fired semi-auto 50
BMG if you've ever if you want the ak-50
to be full auto it lets me know you've
never fired a semi-auto a shoulder fired
50. however what was shoulder as in like
you're holding it up yeah but yeah or or
iPod I have I have a Barrett M82 yeah uh
so you know it's a heavy it's a heavy
sucker oh I could like uh who I can't
remember who you're with but one uh who
was it Luke Luke I think yeah Luke
actually lifted it up and held it he did
not fire it though and he was holding it
but it's like 70 pounds heavy oh it's
it's I think it's 28 pounds or the M82 I
think might be 30 31 wow but it's it's
I've I've shoulder fired a magazine from
it from the Barrett it's it's possible
to do it's just you're gonna be shaky
arms the whole time the uh what's the
other one the RN 52 is that what it's
called
see uh
how's he doing he's doing great man he
was just mentioned like 400 pounds the
other day the man's an animal so uh even
after getting his entire chest I'm glad
that he's that much if he didn't weigh
that much he definitely would have died
we we were out at a range and they had
the rn50 and I didn't want to fire this
one it's a scary gun because the first
person who fired it the Shockwave turned
my phone off oh no so but it put it to
sleep I was I don't whatever that I must
have pushed the button I don't know I
was filming it and I'm I'm holding my
phone up from the sides very close and
and then my phone's off and I was like
what being on the muzzle break being in
the vents of the muscle break on that is
objectively worse than being behind it I
was like I don't want it it's a TBI
machine you shoot that 20 times in a row
you're gonna have a nosebleed I got a
Surefire muzzle brake on my 556 with a
14-5 barrel and that stuff sucks to
stand next to man yeah oh it's miserable
what's TBI traumatic brain injury oh wow
but uh so this was another guy who owned
it and then I bought uh because Luke
insisted he Luke sends me guns non-stop
it's like buy this buy this buy this
that's why I bought a good man yeah I
bought a Barrett M82 and uh
that it's not that bad yeah uh I I I I
think the further away too from the
muzzle on the M82 but uh I had no issue
whatsoever I was like oh 12 gauge my
Remington causes me more shoulder issue
more shoulder pain than the bear because
it's lighter so the weight of the weapon
plays significantly into recoil
especially with a nice muzzle brace
isn't there a recoil spray like a
Buffer's tube and a recoil spring in the
in the parrot so it's a short recoil
system so basically what that means is
that uh every gun every every rifle will
have like lock up that stops the gun
from just exploding right so the breach
is locked when the gun fires short
recoil systems like the Barrett M82 uh
is when the barrel reciprocates a little
bit like an inch or two to unlock the
bolt and so that and it unlocks a little
bit so it doesn't need gas or anything
like that like a normal like AK or ar so
just the short the action of the barrel
moving back unlocks it and then it has a
bigger you know a buffer system Stephen
Stephen Crowder famously got me a I
think a sigma 400 it's called it's been
a while and uh it was very difficult to
get because he had to send it to New
Jersey so they're like it was nuts the
modifications had to be done before can
be sent out and so it took like a year
before I actually got it
and so we went to the we'd go to the
range and I would use like a Harpers
Ferry Armory out here has their own what
they described as mil-spec 556 AR-15 and
then what I got when I finally got the
the Sig from Crowder it's night and day
how amazing it was yeah it was wow I was
just it was what was different it was
easy
that that the way I would describe it is
it it almost felt it felt more like
firing a 22 than firing a 556. like yeah
it was good it was uh I I I'm not I'm
not a gun expert enough to explain
anything beyond I mean I think it's got
like a muzzle break uh I don't know what
else about it easier to aim easier to
handle less recoil obviously I think the
muzzle brake is is causing that a muzzle
break will help a lot but really what a
lot of them do is uh it's gonna be a lot
of Cheaper five five or a cheaper any
any gas operated rifle uh what they'll
do is that they'll they'll over gas it
uh slightly or maybe a lot because they
won't they don't have the technical
Precision to make it super reliable so
they're like okay well if we can't make
it really reliable on good gas we'll
make it super reliable on a lot of gas
so no matter what happens this thing
that bolt carrier is running back the
way though it just shoves it really hard
yeah and so like if you have a uh uh
like a properly gassed well-made gun The
Recoil impulses a lot less because it's
not necessarily just the you know
Newtonian physics of The Recoil of the
gun of the shot going off but a lot of
that's the bolt carrier impact onto the
rear of the gun that's
pushing you know the recoil and pulse
super sharp what's what gas is used so
um in any gas operator in most like
automatic Firearms whatever uh anything
gas off they'll bleed off some gas from
the bullet being fired uh down the
barrel and it'll feed it back in so uh
error 15s Bleed It Off through a little
gas tube uh ARS use a long stroke gas
piston and it just bleeds off from the
barrel and hits the bolt carrier which
then Cycles the firearm that's what
unlocks it let's grab a couple more
Kevin Malone says hey Phil I went to the
baby metal concert in Houston ah and the
opening actor boy Jason is a heck of an
instrumentalist he is the best guitar
player on the planet Earth
all right we'll grab one more my third
nut says Brandon you should propose a
bill so that government officials and
security are only allowed to use
firearms that are readily available for
citizens to use
I'm down for that well I think a lot of
these uh I think a lot of these people
would have different opinions if they
didn't live in you know their nice uh
mansions with private security half of
which funded by taxpayers I think you
have a little bit of a different opinion
agreed all right everybody smash the
like button subscribe to the channel
share the show with your friends head
over to timcast.com click join us become
a member why not only do you get access
to the Discord where you can hang out
with like-minded individuals they
there's an after show every night an
after after show Monday through Thursday
we do the uncensored members only and
then our members created their own show
to hang out afterwards it's the coolest
thing ever you guys rock and uh that was
kind of the Big Goal with creating this
community
so that you guys could talk to each
other share ideas and uh work on
projects and things like that also as a
member every Friday we choose a member
to shout out and promote their brand
product or project uh this week we
didn't do it because we're promoting the
Miami event and we've really gotta push
but you know hopefully next week I think
we'll kick back into full gear start
shouting you guys out again and uh we
just want you guys to know that the goal
of everything we're doing is to build
culture expand culture and win a culture
War so proceeds we generate from you
being a member as a for-profit company
go into our our company for our own
private discretion which tends to be
things like buying Billboards setting up
coffee shops trying to build an
anti-time square or like you know when
we all we all teamed up and you guys
gave super chats and we were able to
contribute to Tim Ballard in the amount
of fifty thousand dollars which have
came from you guys that's the coolest
thing ever and so right now we're
thinking about how do we buy the statue
of Lenin and then desecrate it and I
don't know if we can we're exploring it
just know that if there's one thing I
would I want to do more than anything
else it's not horde money and buy fancy
cars it is buying the statue of Lenin
from Seattle and desecrating it with
filibonti that is like the thing you do
with money on it
you can do that for free now I can't
wait that being said it cost the price
of a a decent sized house so I don't
know if something like that is possible
but that's the general idea of what we
do right the the more we grow the more
we're going to build cultural Endeavors
and just reinvest back into everything
we're already doing so thank you all so
much you can follow the show at timcast
IRL you can follow me personally at
timcast Brandon you want to shout
anything up uh just uh Brandon Herrera
for congress.com is uh where that's the
campaign website where we've got a lot
of good Grassroots support and man I
appreciate you having me on the show
it's been fun anytime dude absolutely
about time we made it happen yeah
finally Brandon is here we appreciate it
uh make sure you vote for him if you're
from Texas I'm Phil Labonte you can
follow me on Twitter I'm at Phil that
remains on Instagram I'm at Phil it
remains official the band is All That
Remains you can follow us on Spotify on
what is it Amazon music Apple music
YouTube you know the internet you follow
me at Ian Crossland everywhere and
anywhere on the internet at Ian
Crossland there it is behind me you want
to get a good look at how to spell that
always a pleasure Brandon really good to
see you and it's the AK guy let me see
the AK guy on Twitter when people follow
you there yes sir looking forward to
talking to you again man I feel like we
could go two hours just talking about
guns absolutely I mean we should it's
all I'm used to yeah maybe we should
have you back for a cultural episode
talk about guns we should all go down
and shoot guns with them it's a better
idea on a weekend it's a weekend they we
go on a weekend when you're not feeling
we're in Texas uh San Antonio so we will
open the whole shop up to you it's
basically an arms Museum we should maybe
maybe we do Tim cast gun week and we go
down don't forget
[Laughter]
um
yeah we could totally do it rock and
roll holidays are coming up so it might
be like February
February is beautiful we're doing the
Michael Mouse Roseanne uh challenge in
January oh yeah we'll be in Austin we
can figure something oh nice yeah
45 minutes away what we want to do
is have a show at the comedy Mothership
with rose uh IRL live with Roseanne and
Michael malice because they had a bet on
this show I think what was the bet that
there would be military tribunals this
year or something that was Roseanne's
yeah right so Michael laughed and said I
will I will bet you that's not the case
and then we all decided let's do a show
where where Michael or Roseanne pays the
other person and we have a good time and
so uh we're gonna be reaching out I
don't know if it's possible I might just
be too soon for the mothership but we
thought it'd be really fun to have like
Roseanne one of the legends of comedy
and we do this political comedy thing so
uh we should be down there yeah because
if it's not there I'll be like Vulcan or
something we'll figure it out that's
that's right down the road it's like an
hour away from us so perfect just rules
sweet Carter Banks
what's up guys when I'm not pressing the
buttons for surgeon calendar making
music a ton of songs that are all almost
done been working on for a while so if
you go to trashouserecords.com you can
get what we've already put out
um Tim cast songs on YouTube Tim cast
music and you can follow me personally
at Carter banks on Twitter and Carter
banks4l on Instagram
so yeah right on right everybody thanks
for hanging out this Friday uh if you
didn't already check out the culture War
episode from this morning A lot of
people are like Tim you have such great
patience and I'm like oh we have to have
these conversations and uh it's for you
guys to to listen to and to share and uh
to to make of it what you will we're
gonna have Clips up throughout the
weekend and then we're back on Monday
and we will see you all then